[Music]
four four four six
i'm nervous how am i nervous
i'm nervous because you're like you're
i'm starstruck by you stop i am chelsea
no way i have been living on your videos
on your instagram videos for years i i
sho i literally show
your videos to people guys i'm dating
and if they don't
like cry laughing i'm like this is a red
flag bounce he doesn't get me
yeah bounce i like that sounds just like
them
yes amen
starting off strong i you you've helped
me like overcome
uh jealous instincts because all i do is
tell the guys i'm dating to look at your
boobs
i'm always like look at her boobs like
i'm con they're like why are you showing
me someone else
so much like i'm like oh i'm turns out
i'm not you know yeah
oh i like that yes you're the hallway
you're every guy i'm i'm dating's hall
pass paul pass
i love it yes how are you feeling are
you nervous
um not anymore just the opening opening
of podcasts
it's always just i get nervous podcasts
are awkward yeah i don't know what it is
but no once we get rolling i'm good
it is a weird thing yeah
that we're doing here yeah most
definitely you've done a lot of podcasts
though
yeah you did theos recently yeah i was
nervous about that i love theo yeah
theo's
oh my god i love legend yeah yeah yeah
um but yeah i do some podcasts just
you know but it is weird because it's
like you know
you're doing these hilarious videos you
do amazing like characters and stuff and
then it's like now
talk for two hours and be boring for two
hours
i i i i never know what i'm supposed to
be doing when i show up for a pie that's
what i
that's okay i like to i like to have a
plan i like to have a
you know i like to write things out i
can you know what i mean so when you're
in a podcast you're just kind of like
what am i saying yes yes and it's cova
time so there's no
no one here it's like awkward yeah we're
hanging out yep i just feel like someone
needs to
i don't know what i'm looking for like a
trophy for being able to
handle how awkward this is yeah i want
someone to acknowledge yep
well i'll acknowledge it for you this is
because people like podcasts are so easy
it's just people hanging out it's
actually like
it's awkward it's a lot of pressure but
it's been more awkward for me because as
soon as i met you
it was i was like oh this bitch like oh
i love her
you know what i mean like not you know
so it's been more awkward to wear like
you meet somebody you're like hey
yeah because you have to be best friends
right away but i feel like
i feel like i know you already so it's
like different you know i've been
obsessed with you for this
i've been obsessed with you for so long
you're my like
i'm like you're like my jenna jameson i
don't know what to say
like like you know i worked with jenna
jameson on something
okay not a porn wait that sounded good
wait that came off
wrong uh we did a i shot a pilot and she
came in for this like fantasy sequence
and all of the crew the guys on the crew
acting really because their whole
teenage years were t
they nutted to her they they came to
this woman yeah
i bet that was i bet that was weird not
only was it weird
they like thought maybe she would know
like that that's what was the best part
about it
that's funny jenna jameson like walks on
the set and everyone's like oh god yeah
like don't make eye contact she doesn't
know that you jerked off to her
furiously and angrily i bet she of does
well she i bet she's like you know
rolling through whole foods
like and she's welcome you're wrong
exactly in the back of her mind dude i
bet a little bit no doubt does i think i
would
jenna jameson liz just walks through
life and is just like yup
exactly welcome for that assist yeah
he's just like the scottie pippen
yeah just like i think i would be that
way i'd be like oh yeah
like yep yep you're welcome you see my
puppy
but but everyone like was like freaking
out and
but she was sort of like i was like why
are you guys acting so weird
like you know because celebrities were
coming on the set
it was like a different kind of fame it
was a kind of fame that was like
like you're my secret thing you're part
of like my
secret routine at night you're like that
with me
i like i show you your videos to people
you're like an inside joke with my
people oh
god thank you so it's very weird to to
me
thank you damn thank you that's a lot
anyway so it's been a pleasure talking
to you yes
so uh tell me like
we don't know each other by the way also
you guys not literally we are not
are we friends i'd say yeah but we just
met
you know we're best friends that just
met yeah but i'm dead serious like i
like that's not weird to me yeah if you
like to me like internet like
instagram friends like you're we're
friends you know what i mean
yes also i think there's a uh where are
you from from
oklahoma where thackerville
thackerville i graduated with 12 people
nothing dirt roads but we have the
world's largest casino
right it was built when i was in high
school 12 people did 12 people go
dude that's why it seems so large people
come from all over the world
world what's the casino called winstar
windstar casino one star casino
they have like everyone in the town work
at the casino oh yeah yeah
literally literally surrounding towns um
yeah dude it's weird because they have
they have like a list
you know singers come and sing and i'm
and there's nothing there's no
restaurants there's no
it's odd it's odd but yep vackerville
oklahoma
but that's fascinating we did when we um
made the
uh reboot of roseanne we gave becky a
job working at a casino
it was it was that is a i mean that's a
big job oh yeah in southern oklahoma
there's two big casinos and that's
that's where everyone works i never
worked there all my family
has and does my sisters did um i worked
at sonic for eight years
how was that you know what okay
i hated it um because i hate the heat
and i was a car hop and it gets so hot
and you know i hated it
but the other day randomly i was driving
i thought
damn i miss working at sonic i missed
the switchboard
taking people's orders through the
speaker i loved that shit
if it rang i'd be the one to run to it
and take everybody's orders and i just
i just missed that isn't that weird i
was like i miss sonic dude
i don't know what what
what about like what's the biggest the
most annoying thing people do when they
order
oh okay i feel like every time i feel
like every time i pull up to a fast food
restaurant i'm like oh this
i'm i'm being so annoying right now yeah
i'm like um yeah that that
hold on what's the that
and my husband does it and he worked
with me at sonic so he should know
yeah so when we're ordering oh my god he
my blood
boiled but like literally they'll ring
in and it's different if you pull up to
like a mcdonald's where you don't have
to ring in
that's different i feel like but you've
been to a sonic haven't you yes of
course you go to a sonic
you push the red button that lets us
know you're ready to order
uh-huh we answer it and then you run
over no you answer it from inside
through a speaker yeah welcome to sonic
can i take your order today yeah do it
dude how you doing
i would literally go welcome to sonic
this is chelsea how can i help you
and they'll say um uh
um and i'm literally like bitch you
press the button
you're supposed to be ready and i'm
literally like
shit's buzzing shit's going i'm you know
what i mean like that's annoying
that is so annoying um you you you
called me over i'm here
yeah yeah exactly we've agreed that
you're ready
yeah and i know what this business is
you drove here
and i would literally be like do you do
you need a minute no i'm ready
okay uh that's the most annoying
and i would say the second most annoying
is when you would take people's orders
out and they wouldn't even acknowledge
you
walk up to the car hi how are you
literally oh see and that happens
i'm the opposite but is it more annoying
because i'm the person that
wants to like make a best friend no
that's great
because i'm like hi how are you how's
everything going like i i'm like
where are you from like i'm i'm the
annoying person that holds up the line
because i want to
yes to the person at sonic no i remember
um
i remember okay i remember one time
walking up to a car and i'm like hey how
you doing today and she goes
do you really care i'll never forget
that
and i was like that's some bed and shit
that's some shit benton would say
i was like sure i was like uh you know i
don't know i
guess not you know and then one time i
took this lady's order out
and she was a young girl and i was like
hey how are you and she was like
i'm not too good i just found out my
best friend killed herself and i
literally was like
oh like what like what do i do
[Applause]
ketchup looks like blood sorry it just
so can you just splatter some blood
but i i don't know i kind of miss it in
a weird way
you know yeah i don't know do you are
you feeling like
um uh getting recognized and being
famous is that weird to you
yeah yes is it not to you
i mean you you've been you know for a
while now but
yeah in a good way uh
not in a bad way but i'm always shocked
i'm like you know who i am
type of thing you know and i'm like what
um
yeah cause i don't i don't know i
thought fame would feel
different uh-huh i thought do you think
it was okay
i thought when you're famous you'll feel
famous
no does that make sense no when you're
famous you feel lonely and
sad really everyone just asks you for
money
oh that's starting to happen people
people assume that if
someone recognizes you on the street all
of a sudden you have a billion dollars
yes
there's no there's nothing it's you can
be famous and
broke yep you can people do not people
do not and i used to think that
if you're famous i thought you're rich
people think you get a dollar for every
time
someone recognizes you like 100 bills
just start going up your bank account
that's not how
it works you can be famous and not rich
yeah most of these jobs out here do not
pay that well
right like so a lot of people that are
known and and it's so interesting and
getting famous off the internet people
are like
come up to you and it's like can you
please play for my dental surgery yeah
like wait what no i'm just trying to
make you laugh
and now i have to hit your pay pal yep
dms every day probably someone's asking
me for money
why are they asking you for money all of
a sudden i guess they think because i
guess they think the thing
you know you're famous you're rich yeah
hopefully one day
you know but no but the
the thing i thought when you're famous
you'll feel famous and i don't feel
famous
so that's why it's weird
infamous more than famous name the movie
amigos
um i don't know you know what i mean
like do you feel famous
no i'm totally dysmorphic about that
kind of stuff really i have no clue how
i'm perceived
like yeah when someone comes up to me
and like asks me for a photo i'm like
how do you know me
like i i'm i'm rude to them at this
point
because i'm just so curious i'm like why
do you know me
yeah and you know just because it used
to be like
you're on this tv show you're on this
you're on this it's people will find you
now and
yeah foreigners have read it or on
youtube or whatever and they discover
you in different places now
and so i'm like i don't know what
version of me you know right so i don't
know how to show up for you
i like it i don't know what you're a fan
of yes like are you a fan of me
writing about having eating disorders
and in drug addictions
are you because when yeah i have to when
someone walks up to me i have to fur
or have you just seen me be like funny
in a tv show yeah or see me on the
roasts and just want to like
um call me a cunt in the airport for the
next two hours like
fuck around i have to like ascertain
from the fan
how do you know me and how do you want
me to show up for you
yeah see i no that's it's not that way
with me at all
because i think people know me from one
you know one thing you know tammy or
whatever instagram
but no um it's super weird for me but
i'm like without getting cheesy i'm like
always so thankful totally every time
someone comes up they're like i'm so
sorry to bother you i'm like
you're not bothered we live for this you
are not it's my dream
that you don't recognize me yeah yeah
like you are you kidding you're not
bothering me like i love it like let's
take five pictures you know
yeah but it's definitely weird for sure
super weird
and then let me ask you what was you
before you were making videos what was
your goal
in terms of your like career goals um
well okay growing up i always want to be
on snl
yeah and i recently went through my old
um books was there like an snl
sketch that was like oh god
mine was landshark landshark there was a
dan aykroyd
um doing land shark my dad would do it i
would
like landshark remember that sketch yeah
gilda radner it was like
there was a time when these sketches
were like yeah
in the zeitgeist so deeply that it was
inside jokes like with our families
yeah that's what great comedy and great
content does
it gives you something to laugh about
for the rest
an inside joke that goes on and on oh
that's
i like that yeah and you do you do that
with your videos yeah um
but that's what yeah mine was like early
2000s
early like late 90s early 2000s the
whole cast like
chris farley yeah like that whole yeah
like that was my i wanted to be on snl
and i went through my um high school
yearbooks and i saw i had forgotten
about this
you know it said like where do you want
to be in 10 years or whatever
and i was like i'm moving to hollywood
and i'm becoming an a-list
high-paid comedic actress i was like i
can't believe i've
you know i don't remember that you know
but but things like that
don't i thought at the time this is how
things like that don't happen to people
like me
like that's what i thought i got married
still married the same dude
you know i was god 21. and we got
married and
got married at 21 after being together
how long
three years wow yeah wow yeah yeah
he's still tapping it too yeah yeah
i have a lot of questions we're gonna
come okay
okay chelsea lynn's advice on how to
keep a man is coming up
oh gosh how to keep a man satisfied
billy self-care self-care is very
important self-care is very important
and not only
look i mean razors are a nightmare and
i shave so fast i refuse to slow down
well that's a great razor that is a
really i mean it will slide through it
the horses of hair and i also i'm gonna
uh shave my mustache for you guys right
now to show you that
look how safe it is look at this look
how not bleeding she is
i just shave my face all the time i
shave my chin
i is this not let's shave your head see
if it gets through that yeah let's see
how good this razor really is
yeah let's go for it but they don't just
have razors they also have dry shampoo
they have face wipes
these are new they have lip balms um and
they just released their
three complete clean must have product
set
that's pretty cool this is so good these
are wipes these are vitamin c
and how do you say hyaluronic acid yeah
hyaluronic acid
hyaluronic oh this is good soaked in a
gentle blend of cleansers
that remove makeup yeah they're really
great
the razors are really chic also their
slogan time to give
your lady bod some love bye-bye did you
see me that's how i started every
challenge
did you see that and to express a little
love for our show
go to mybilly.com
whitney it's a small way you can support
us uh willist
getting the best razor you will ever own
it's just nine dollars to get your
starter kit plus free
shipping always okay pull it together
your body's gross go to mybilly.com
whitney spelled mybillybiloie.com
school loans i refuse to pay them
i won't do it i'm not gonna do it in
fact i refused to go to school when i
was there
so now what are you gonna do yeah i'm
not gonna pay you if i didn't even i
didn't even
uh acquire yeah i didn't even go and
that's obviously your fault
but i didn't should have gave me money
when i was 12. you sure
you should i didn't have the i didn't
know how to what to do with that money
you told me my loans were gonna be so
rough later i would have actually gone
to class guys
i wouldn't want all those concerts but
ernest can help you with that earnest
offers
low rate student loan refinancing you
can also check your rate risk-free in
just two minutes
they'll consolidate all your payments
together they have a flexible payment
plan
i mean just you need to just sign up for
it quit being overwhelmed by debt
yeah it's like it's it's just like i
mean we talked about it before but it's
like it really is the kind of thing you
have no idea what you're signing up for
when you're
yeah college i'll be able to afford this
later because you think
that everything pays a hundred thousand
dollars yeah and the trick is you'll
never be able to afford anything ever
that's right
that's the real truth you think you get
to keep all the money you make too
like back when you said yes to this you
were like oh and then do you want to
pass away and then leave all your loans
to a loved one
probably not yes if that's a possibility
and i know
that was an option well not in this hand
is that an option
for some people yes oh but with ernest
you don't have to
ernest is offering our listeners a
hundred dollar cash bonus refinance your
student debt at earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply now
ernest is giving our listeners a hundred
dollar bonus refinance your student
loans at earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply once
again you get a 100 cash bonus when you
visit earnest.com
whitney to refinance your student loans
not available in all states terms and
conditions apply
visit earnest.com whitney for more
details turn the conditions apply
earnest student loans refinancing made
by earnest operations llc nmls number
one two zero four nine one seven
california financing law license number
six zero five four seven eight eight
three zero three second street suite 401
north san francisco california 94107.
visit earnest.com
license for a full list of licenses but
what was i saying yeah
um what was i saying about just sort of
like your
oh yeah and you know things like that
don't you know so we got married moved
to dallas i was
working at the mall where things
remembered
oh you worked in the things remembered i
love that it fucking sucked i hated it
more than what was the weirdest
engraving someone ever asked for oh dude
i
no i know exactly okay dude things
remembered i i i'm such an asshole as a
kid i was like let's do prank things
remembered and do like a prank frame
that's like suck my dick
oh people would come in but can you like
this is the inside i'm like i'll do it
i'll
put anything you want but one time this
um
couple came in they're probably in their
late 40s and i'll
never forget this dude they came in and
they brought in urns because you could
bring in stuff too
and they brought in earnest for
themselves
and his said something like and i i kept
i kept the paper he wrote this on and i
have it somewhere this is how
ridiculous it was and he wanted me to
write something like
he was a scholar and a great man
and he was one just like literally and
he wrote that himself to put on
and i just i'll never forget that and i
put it on there but
yeah man that's actually so much more
embarrassing than something like super
sexual and kinky just to be
a scholar a scholar huh
a scholar that's what got me it says who
i know that's what i'm saying what is
the skull like what how do you define
define scholar
i don't know who to who decides these
things like he decided is there a
certificate
is there proof who's proof so you can't
so you can't just
so you scholarly someone on their
instagram bio calls themself a
photographer you're like
i guess yeah are we all photographers
yes
you're a scholar like what you've read
books are we all scholars
wait hold on i'm dying i know a scholar
what is a scholar
i don't know how to google it
i'm a scholar you know who know a
scholar a scholar would know
maybe he was a scholar i think is it
like an educated person
what's a scholar that is such a fake job
that's not a real person and you don't
put it on your urn
that's like that's like being a ball of
like
like like a bomb like i'm like um
uh uh uh how do you um i've never heard
of that
do you know what i mean like it's a word
yeah it's not real nobody uses it
nobody uses a scholar a scholar but
nobody uses it but it's so vague nobody
challenges it
because no one knows why it's wrong i
hate this shit
this is the shit that pisses me off the
shit that smart people say
to make other smart people think they're
stupid yep you're gaslighting me i'm a
scholar
yeah i'm a scholar what's the definition
that's like this is like when
when um i learned that
guys aren't really allergic to latex
[Laughter]
like the time you learn like
[Applause]
it's like the word playwright is spelled
wrong playwright
w-r-i-g-h-t uh-huh why is it spelled
wrong
yeah why playwright you guys are
supposed to be smart you're supposed to
know how to
play right just spell right right why am
i the asshole because i spelled that
wrong
yeah i hate it when words make you the
stupid one
yeah a smart word and i don't spell good
to begin with
i don't i'll admit it i'll admit it the
the uh autocorrect has made it so that
i'm truly illiterate
yeah yep have you tried to write a
handwritten card recently
oh god my handwriting is yeah it's scary
and i gotta think about it
you know you you know you gotta i'll
literally be like uh hold on
which there do i gotta use here tgi are
you why
i'm that person and i'm tired and i'm re
what's the difference
in there oh don't ask me do not
there they are is t-h-e-y
oh possibly i have to see it hold on i
get to see it so this is
by the way in you motherfucker's comment
section they'll correct you they'll
they'll let us know oh yes they all will
let us know and i just want to say
i didn't go to one elementary school i
blame it on that okay i went to like
nine elementary schools and
well my parents were drug addicts so i
think i uh
i think i just missed that part
of learning you missed the the the um
what i'm supposed to know uh conjugation
yeah uh
yep semester i couldn't tell you what a
pronoun is i couldn't either
okay good hold on what's a pronoun uh
don't know i know what a noun is
that's a thing yeah an adjective is
most of us don't know this honestly if
you were to really this is
i went through this on roseanne because
it makes me crazy
when people are like just speak you know
roseanne's whole thing is just because
we're poor doesn't mean we're stupid
just because from the south doesn't mean
we're stupid
most people do not know no this shit
no and the people listening like i do
well good for you well okay
you're googling it and you know it right
and you're a liar and how dare you
and
ask me noun pronoun adjective
is descriptive word so like she's
she adjective she's very pretty that's
an adjective that's it
pretty is the adjective very is the
qualifier
what's my brain's hurting oh start to
throb
and also who gives a fuck yes thank you
who gives oh my god thank you i am a
professional writer
my check's clear because i put words and
documents
get the fuck out of here who cares
people pay me to write words
they don't care i literally you know
what's so funny about this i am a
professional writer for a living i've
never gotten a note from an executive
saying this is spelled wrong
it's only people on the fucking internet
you motherfuckers
yup nitty gritty i love that
and my sister smart and she'll oh god
she pisses me off like
dude i was helping uh my two nieces live
with me eight and ten and one of them
needed help and
it was something like oh pronoun i'm
like you're gonna go ask beth
literally she came back like uh you
don't know what a pronoun is
wait that pronouns for like transgender
pronoun like pronouns like oh maybe i'm
messing up wait
wait no a pronoun is a part of wait
right wait wait i don't know
there were pronouns before there were
like pronouns right right that's what
i'm thinking yeah oh
see i didn't even i think so oh see i
was just going home
yeah there is yeah yeah i was going to
the this is how old i am
i was going to pronounce like what a pro
yeah
okay yeah okay you're alert yeah
pronouns used to just be pronouns right
which i don't know what now they're like
a
statement yes of your identity and you
get in trouble if you get it wrong yes
okay yeah pronouns you what's a pronoun
okay pronouns used to just be okay i
realized
now i'm sweating yeah oh my god now i'm
so str i'm getting canceled whatever i
just i'm happy that i thought we were
just having a conversation about grammar
and we just walked into a piece of pc
nightmare
well i'm just happy that you didn't put
me down for not knowing grammar
and that you you know are walking hand
in hand with me through this
it's you know that's like i'm like you
know what are we doing
you fucking dork all the hall monitors
that need to like
police and you know what if i see
something that's misspelled or misused
which
i don't know anyway so it's rare that i
ever do that
but if i see something i don't give a
fuck
who cares but by the way when you
misspelled me a text i know what you
were trying to say
did i i did
i don't even know by the way but you
know what i was saying yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah and why do i have to now
right
but it's so weird cause when i'm like
this is ducking stupid i'm like yeah
you know you know that was an
autocorrect just be a good person
yeah if it's not that hard if i said
there and i meant there
you know what i mean don't be an asshole
thank you what are we doing
what okay what do you want a check at
the end yeah
oh or or apostrophe oh you're better
than me you're better than me
is that what you want me to say okay
i'll say it
you're better than me great you you but
i have better tits
nerd your kids are incredible
thank you how do you manage them
um i don't who manages the who
who manages handles your tits just me
this is solo
this is solo i thought you'd have
someone i thought there was going to be
a truck
a process no no and
uh cotton gin and eli whitney like
some kind of dude my tits have been
saggy since i was 12.
i just want to say that for real i'm not
even kidding you
and i remember being in um um fifth or
sixth grade and having c cups
and i was not fat as a kid i just want
to point that out everybody's going back
well because you were fat
you know no i was thin as a kid i had
huge tits
let me break this down because it is
interesting what is
a cup abcd that's the cup size
and that's the width of the boob that's
the filt
filt you're filling up filling it
whatever you're feeling is the cup
the number is the circumference of your
rib cage
yep is that how bra sizing works bra
sizing is a very enigmatic
mysterious thing and it gets worse the
bigger your tits are
because you can you can go into a
victoria's secret
32 see
me
you know you can go in there i can't go
into any store
and i gotta start talking gibberish when
i go into the big titty store i wanna
you walk into the victorian secret what
does that look like i used to work at
tory's secret
what yep i sure did i let go
awful dude worse i hated it i hated it
dude
they i only worked there for like a
month what do they say is it more
meant okay do men go in and buy lingerie
for women or women buying lunch
for themselves who goes in with
victoria's here at store
mostly women but i would have dudes come
in and be totally uncomfortable and be
like
uh i'm gonna spend 200 can you just pick
some stuff out and i'll just pick
whatever out
but they ha can you find me something to
come on later yeah yeah like
when a guy goes into lingerie store he's
like what do i want to come on what do
you yeah that's basically what he's
thinking right
what do i want to see my come on yeah
how are those tits going to look
what it like what is worthy of my cum
ruining isn't that basically what a
lingerie story is for a man
but that's what i would say what she
wants are these comfortable
yeah she wants these she wants some pink
sweats
she wants is what she wants yes
yeah that's what do you do when a guy
comes in and is like what should i get
my girl for valentine's day
these cozy slippers and this onesie
yup or this thing full of wires and
tetanus over here
i would ask them like do you want do you
want you know something sexy or
whatever and they what do you say no
tell me i would literally be like well
are you wanting something
you know sexy like lingerie anal you
know
yeah like you have to ascertain like
what dude they would get so
uncut like literally like it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter like almost
like
just kid or whatever and that's weird
but they're terrified
what did they tell you about her no i
just and then i just literally just
picked
some shit out that i wouldn't even wear
myself i'm like oh this is good
i didn't work there very long they made
me give hand massages to people and
that's when i was like i'm out
what you had to wear this um little uh
one of those really cool like uh
microphones you know so i felt important
like
like a madonna holiday yeah it was like
yeah like and i don't know if they do
those anymore and then anyway like
someone would come in
and then my manager would be in the back
literally i'm like that lady would that
lady just walked in go give her a hand
massage
what do you mean so i'd have to and i've
never been in a victoria secret i mean i
haven't been one in years but
where i've seen this done so i think it
was just me
but i'd have to go are you coming out
with your story of being molested
so like just let me emotionally prepare
it i'd have to go up and be like
hey how are you today you know good um
this is our
most popular um lotion angel it's called
angel
and uh would you like to give would you
like me to give you a hand massage i'll
just you know and that literally most
people would be like
no that's okay wait he told you to offer
people hamish yeah it was a chick yeah
yep and if they said yes
did that which i would say 25 percent of
the time they said yes what
which is even weirder and i would
literally
they would literally just hear this and
i would squirt some
lotion but you're not a trained masseuse
no
i was just rubbing lotion on their hands
like what's well that's
what what what's your plate let's say
literally say i'm a customer
you're you're working a victoria's
secret you're doing it now let me put
this on you yeah
okay like hi how are you okay that's
expensive okay
don't waste my shit okay i'm like hi how
are you today hey
hi how are you good yeah uh let me uh
tell you about our most popular scent
it's called angel ma'am
it's called angel and it was called
angel i remember that
and i'd be like would you like a
like would you like a hand massage okay
say yes i'll give you a quick hand
massage okay i'm just over here
here let me see your hand yeah
i see it just give let me give you a
quick hand massage
and this is literally what i would do
dude i thought i'm sorry
i didn't like that i need to pull it
together hold on tight
and i would and i would and i would what
just happened was so real you're going
man they were just so it was so real
i would literally pray they would say no
oh you came in so committed
oh but i know you want me to say no oh
oh i would say please say no please it's
such an amazing experience to watch how
hard you're committing to something that
you don't want to do
yes okay so sorry and when they would
say yes
um that's probably not a big reach for
me i'm the asshole customer
uh putting on uh makeup ignoring you
yeah go
okay hello how are you today hi thank
you hi
hey uh let me i want to tell you about
our um most uh popular scent it's called
angel oh yeah yeah would you like a hand
massage just real quick
why real quick because i'm not gonna do
it for an hour
you know you got things to do but should
i smell it why am i oh yeah that's oh i
would do that
why would i be gonna
if this was like 15 years ago
this is our fav this is our most popular
scent angel
i would hold it up like this uh-huh
remember probably the k and then in
pre-covered times when you could just
take oh yeah
oh yeah the good days and then okay
mm-hmm thank you so it's good would you
like a hand massage
and i always wonder what went through
there never had someone ask
and every time they said yes i would
literally be like
why i want in my head i would literally
be like this is how i would do it
i would grab their hands i'd be like
and then i would never say anything i'm
just
going to start shitting just
kind of looking okay you're pretending
you know how to
what's going on in your mind you're
pretending you're a member i'm thinking
oh god like how long is this you know
what i mean look what time is it
oh that work i worked i worked evening
shifts it's like in the evening
and it was always older women that said
yes
i i knew that older women that said yes
and then i would say someone just want
to touch someone else
yeah like what have you like because
when i worked um i worked in a store
a clothing store when i first moved to
la and it was such
great uh like education
on human nature like i think as
comedians it's our like we need to
understand
like what people need what people want
how deeply emotional we are working in
retail
help me learn that people are just
yeah so emotional and unpredictable
and um i just feel like i learned so
much
about human nature yeah when i was on
the when
what people decide to spend their money
on like what did you learn working in
retail
about like human nature oh gosh dude
because benton will always be like
because we work on packaging for like
new merch and stuff like that he's like
people don't they just want it's an
emotional decision
you know robert greene was saying that
in a store
if you are a salesperson if you touch
the customer
uh if there's a chance that they'll buy
something
uh the chance that they'll buy something
goes up 80 wow if you touch them
i didn't know that if you just touch
their shoulder whoa
that's crazy that's probably why thank
you that woman was having you massage
strangers oh
yeah well i mean you were also molested
yeah and you should file a
criminal report dude um
i think okay so i've done retail
i've done fast food and i think like for
me
the only thing it taught me was how to
fucking treat people
you know what i mean in terms of comedy
i don't know i
you know what it did you know cause i i
don't know if you get nervous before but
i
want to go home right before they
announce me i'm like i want to go home
right now
i'm seriously thinking about walking out
what happens
oh god i i'm going to puke and i'm like
why i always think
why am i doing this what why did i sign
up for this
well what was i thinking
and then i get on stage and it's
completely it's like great you know what
i mean so it's just weird
but i think doing shit like that at
victoria's secret probably helped me to
like
you know like curry like you know like
just courage and time to do
uncomfortable things that is so
profound thank you i love i've been
falling in love with you
yeah it is it's like all these like you
know every shitty job i had
prepared me for being a comic or
prepared me for being
a boss or whatever i have to because you
have to like walk up to strangers and
embarrass yourself yeah that's what it
is
yes essentially all the time and you
have to like make super uncomfortable
situations
like laugh it off that's what we're
doing here we know this is awkward but
we're going to do it anyway that's
kind of with everything you're saying is
great for that like that
i could not waitress i i couldn't last
20 seconds really
yeah i didn't last um i but i worked in
a clothing store
out here and it was like people looking
at clothes i'm like
where you get it or not and you're like
oh there's like
i my job right now is to just yeah talk
you through your childhood
like this isn't about buying a sweater
and not buying a sweater yeah like
you're going through a different like i
need to get you to stop crying
yeah like it's just like it's so you see
people at their
worst probably right yeah i could
definitely see that yeah and i never
thought about any of this so you brought
it up but like
just freaking you know going to an
audition or whatever just
a meeting i hate meetings what do you
mean you hate me
oh my even if it's with people i know
it's just
just uncomfortable and with what i do
you know you just have to there's so
many uncomfortable
you just gotta do it you gotta push
yourself and so i think definitely stuff
you know how like emotionally
uncomfortable like you're just like
i don't know dude i just get if they ask
me to talk i'm like fuck
i gotta talk you know uh uh well
that's fascinating to me because it's
like you know as comedians i think we're
all trying to figure out like in this
new moment of like
stand up sitcoms movies digital
you know tick tock like how are we
um gonna get to our fans how are we
gonna give content to our fans
and there was a way that we used to do
it but now it's sort of like
in order to you know be a successful
famous comedian you also have to be a
business person behind the scenes yeah
and usually the kind of childhood
and neurology that made someone really
funny is probably not the same neurology
that's going to make someone like
great at logistics and running a
business so now comedians
are expected to be the silly clowns and
also like
elon musk yeah and it's like no the i
just
kind of want to shake my tits and tell
dick jokes and now
i'm like in a business meeting and i
yeah like i'm talking to hr like
no no we're idiots that's yeah that was
my whole thing yep
and now i agree now you know
the people that signed up to be clowns
are sitting at the head of a
a conference table being like with a
bunch of suits being like
you know no i just was fucking around my
friends having fun yep
yeah you're out that's how i feel now
you're asking me about like percentages
and numbers and shit that i and
so i just pretend i understand yeah oh
i'm i'm great at pretending you have to
you have to i'm great at pretending this
is good this is really important because
you you getting successful so fast with
no blueprint
there's no blueprint for this no you
there's no one to ask like
you know i can call and i can call
shelly duvall and be like hey
i can call people and go how to navigate
hollywood but like
this is also young and new yeah the
whole internet
thing yeah agree i think you're gonna
you're the dolly partner of instagram
i would like for chelsea lynn to be the
dolly part of instagram
we will look back in 50 years oh
sugar oh my god
thank you i'm obsessed with her you know
you know that um
that's awesome thank you thank you thank
you um
yeah the whole like i don't know the
you know how like there's what analytics
you were saying analytics yeah someone
was talking to me
the other day some content creator and
he's like oh ask me questions
oh how many blah blah what are your
intelligent i'm like i don't know what
you're talking about he's like you don't
ever look on your thing
i don't know he's like you could be
making so much more money i'm like
okay i don't know what you're talking
about i don't think about that
one i i i worry about writing something
or
whatever i'm whatever i'm doing once
it's posted
i don't even look at how many views it
has you know what i mean because that's
not weird that's weird to me
i just want to do it i don't want to do
all that that's the whole thing
you're i don't and
wow and this is part of i why i think
there's such a purity to what you do and
why
there's such a freedom in what you do
and i and such a joy in it because
you know i came up having to look at
metrics and numbers
and so and overthinking things and
everything uh
this has to hit a certain amount of
numbers like the fun
that has been taken out of the process
of making entertainment
so entertainers are no longer having fun
so entertainers are no longer
able to be fun yeah i'm saying because
because yeah it used to be like
they go on a stage and they freak out
and they you know gallagher's like
smashing watermelons and
like that would never have worked on
instagram that would never have you know
worked if there was what's working now
is just like
so different and because there's this
immediate feedback and there's this
immediate
um punishment or reward for something
yeah where is it like it used to be like
you could like fuck up for a while and
n something haven't something not work
for a while and then get better
yeah in private on stage yeah now it's
like you put it out for instagram like
you can get demoralized before you're
you know while you're just practicing
like yeah no one's supposed to have it
all figured out
yeah right away yeah your followers
expect you to they're if you're
followers like you have to be
yeah the peak of your career as soon as
you start yeah and you have to
stay that way you have to stay that way
stay that way it's amazing how like
tom cruise is able to have a couple bad
movies you'll still see mission
impossible
forget about the fucking has what is a
bad
tom cruise movie oh it's about example
god
i don't know i couldn't i can't even
listen for like
ben affleck or whatever yeah yeah that's
a lot of good ones but we forget about
giggly or jiggly yeah yeah you can't
have a bad video they just fucking
unfollow you write that in there yeah i
know
damn you know so true it's like there's
there's more you know we have less uh uh
what's the word like um
shorter leash now because there's so
many people doing it
yeah there's so many people doing it um
yeah like dude i'll post a video and
most of my thing most of my stuff's
bangers i will say
but i agree yeah you're like i don't
have this problem uh
my fans have never just like anything
i've ever posted because i nail it every
time bitch
but fair every once in a while i'll have
like a comment like
not your best and i'm like but look at
all these people that did enjoy it i
don't give a fuck
you have such a healthy why do you have
such a healthy
mindset thank you why do you have that
what's going on i don't know i don't
know so you casually you're just like i
was raised by drug addicts
oh yeah yeah i was raised by addicts for
sure but no sometimes i'll do like a
certain video and it
won't get a whole lot of views or love
but the the few that do
i keep doing that because they you know
like um i'm trying to think of it i
can't think of an example but
you know what i mean i'm like i i don't
have to put out things that go viral
every time i post i don't give a shit
you know as long as few people love it
that's great that's great
yes you don't put a lot of pressure on
yourself no i put zero
good zero should be yeah zero that's how
it should be
do you talk about your childhood much or
no yeah um
oh i don't mind talking about it i've
talked about it um
i've talked about on instagram and i was
on um the honeydew podcast you know he
gets deep
yeah um ryan zickler and we talked about
it on there
um yeah so my parents had me
young i'm the oldest of three girls and
they had me when they were 17 i think
and um it was planned that was obviously
planned
carefully planned and uh i got we got
taken away when i was 12.
lost custody and and my grandma raises
from there on out so from like birth to
dude i don't know how like i look back
and i'm like how did i turn out
half-assed decent did you ever have to
go into court
um i never did but there was court dates
about me
type of thing because i have a theory i
have a little theory going here
uh because i was in a custody battle
as a kid and i had to go into court and
i had to testify and that was my first
like yeah people are looking at me i
like this
oh you liked it that was like my first
stand-up set how old were you
i it's such a blur i was probably eight
oh wow
you liked it i was like like it was like
like i have a theory that people that
grew up in acrimonious
yeah situations are like you know bad
divorces and were taken away and had to
speak for themselves and had to advocate
for themselves as children
grow up to be comedians yeah you know or
grow up to be
uh sort of comfortable being seen
because
speaking in front of people for a lit is
a very uh
unnatural weird it's weird it's it's not
natural humans are not designed to get
up in front of people and go i'm gonna
make you laugh all day you know yeah
it's
it's terrifying yeah and since the
pandemic i've like gotten
more scared of it like really oh my god
after not doing stand up for six months
and then i started touring them
you did those parking lot shows those
parking lot shows with taylor tomlinson
and um
i'm i just booked a bunch of uh club
shows and i'm doing some car shows
outside in california
but i remember going on teaching like oh
my god like how have i
done this for the past 15 years like i
literally i was so
nervous going on stage like after it
wasn't
uh like that muscle had kind of
activated something oh wow
um dude i i hope
i hope it because i've only done stand
up twice well
two weekends multiple show i think i had
done like 10 shows right now
yeah nashville and then dallas a year
ago before before pandemic um
the best oh my god dude i but i've never
done open mics
yeah i've never done you know what i
mean so to go in
so you missed the like i missed getting
molested by comedians in the 90s yeah
you got to miss all that part
miss bombing i you know i don't you got
to go straight to like
fans which i feel like was even
i feel like that's even uh scarier wow
because you feel like you owe them or
something or i feel like maybe they
expect they're like you know what i mean
if you do an open mic
or people don't know who you are you're
open whatever people aren't there to see
you
it almost doesn't if you bomb you know
they're not there to
yeah you know whatever but if they're
there to see
you and they've driven and they've got a
business
and you gotta you know and they're like
i'm
you know it's more way more pressure
that's so interesting and i'm not and i
hope i'm not like
talking you out of your process but i i
i feel i look i'm like oh my god that's
as a as a fan i would come to show me
like
there's nothing you can do at this point
that would make me unhappy
that's what everybody says it's like
because i
i came up at a time where it was like i
you had to prove yourself
yeah every second was like you could
lose them at any moment
they had no idea who i was and
when people are coming to see you
they're they're so much more forgiving
like
i feel like there's this um there's this
negativity towards
our fans sometimes that is because
because uh a lot of comedians were wired
to be negative
right we're wired to be like this
motherfucker isn't laughing how many
yeah
before instagram we came up in such an
ad we had such an adversarial
relationship with the audience
and maybe you guys uh people that got
famous on instagram
feel it too because of the comment
section you know how critical people can
be
but i feel like we forget how much
people actually just fucking
love us like they love you yeah we put
some
we our expectations for ourselves are so
much higher than
yeah and it's funny because you said
like what the whole internet
video thing i put zero pressure on
myself zero
but when it comes to stand up that's
where all my pressure goes yeah
for sure and it should be that's a
healthy that you should
take it seriously but also it's like i
just feel like there's this mentality of
like
that the audience is like yeah yeah like
people are supportive yeah i think that
the comment sections on twitter and
instagram and youtube have given us a
false sense of how negative people are
i don't think people are as bad as we
think they are is that naive
no i agree with that for sure i think
people show up and they want to laugh
and they want to enjoy the show
it's the the negative people are the
ones that go out of their way to write
the yelp review yeah
out of their way to make the negative
comments but i think we're biased
because
we we weigh the negative yeah more
heavily in our brains
yeah i just got to think um you know
those negative commenters
aren't buying tickets i didn't think
about that until
but you're right like the people there
are they're the ones that have been you
know
supporting so yeah that's so true
we need a little break we do need to
break there's a small break
i need a break from the merriment too
much fun
so if you have a personality like me and
men can't get it up
we can help because talking about
erectile dysfunction
isn't easy but that was you know what it
was for me to say all that
yeah that was really hard for me to get
into uh
excuse the pun um you don't want to say
things like i'm just not feeling it
or i'm tired or this always happens
or no it never happens or i don't think
you say it always happens that's
probably not the answer
this always happens with you i've can
you
stop looking at me turn the lights off
can you pretend to be someone else
yeah you're not scarlett johansson it's
so weird yeah could you just
um put your head in this bag but with
roman you don't have to do that
because roman makes it easy to talk
about roman is the sponsor guys
um you can talk with a healthcare
professional a real helicopter
professional i like that they had to
clarify the real part very important by
the way you should we're not talking
like
dr tim dillon yeah it's safe simple
totally discreet fucking zinc
very discreet that's important um
everything's free uh you get a free
online evaluation it's all done online
they ship it right to your door
discreetly
go get roman.com whitney today if
approved you'll get 15
off your first order of e.t treatment
that's get roman.com
whitney getroman.com and no the
treatment's not just a photo of me
are you comfortable emotionally
you would probably be more comfortable
if you have brooklyn and cheese
or towels or you know pajama sets the
brooklyn and towels
not that i have taken a shower in four
months
uh based on the look of me but these
towels are
yeah they're really nice they're like
little
clouds i had no idea until i had these
towels that
i just had tails move the water around
and that it eventually just evaporates
this is like you put it on it's like the
water's just gone
i was pretty sure taos just raked water
off of me
into a puddle on the floor yeah then i
laid the towel down on the puddle on the
floor
but not with this have you ever like
smelled your towels and like
oh like they're you're supposed to get
new towels every six months which i did
not know
well you know what i like about this
towel i'll be really honest it's big
enough that it wraps around my whole
body
i mean you know how hard it is to find a
towel that fits around your entire body
this is a it's also by the way just like
it's so uh
this is a comforter actually yeah i know
exactly they're comforters
which i have one i like
to be um cold
at night like i like to sort of like get
in and then get warm and they have a
lightweight comforter because the
heavier comforters i get sweaty and it's
just i wake up in a pool of sweat and
it's just not
not yet yeah and there's not yet i'll do
that my four days
sheets pillows duvet covers are all
great i mean they have
75 000 five star reviews and counting
whoa that's pretty fancy so you should
treat yourself to the ultimate comfort
with brooke
lennon's comfort collection go to
brooklyn.com and use promo code whitney
to get 25
off with a minimum purchase of a hundred
dollars that's b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com
and enter promo code whitney for 25
off with a minimum purchase of a hundred
dollars that's brooklyn.com
promo code whitney dude respect yourself
get in your sheets last night i was
playing for my lover
um playing playing
what do you mean like guitar imagine me
lifting a finger
no imagine me lifting a finger in a
relationship playing guitar well like
playing guitar
serenading him um buying him a guitar so
he'll like
stop talking to me um uh no i was
playing a vid the video of you
oh your boobs and um
it was just i was thinking about you and
i was talking about you with my
lover and you seem to have this like the
most amazing marriage
yeah we have a good
oh god i think um married at 21
met at 17. i would just turn 18. like
just turned 18.
a month ago how long have you been
married
let's do the math uh like 12 years yeah
we've been 15.
15 years yeah i don't feel old enough to
be with someone 15 years
why why how did this happen how how is
this um
possible we so okay so he
here's what i think it is like when i
say there is zero
jealousy and zero control on both of our
ends
i mean that hardcore i dude and i have
such a crazy personality
and i'm very sexual and i'm for you know
and he has never once
been like you know people will comment
what does your husband think about this
huh like what do you like no no no i've
never told him once he can't go anywhere
he can't do anything he i don't want him
talking to that girl i don't give a shit
you know what i mean like so i think
that i could i don't think i could be
with someone that um
had a problem with me being the way i
was
yeah yeah yeah do you so you never are
you know making your content and being
like uh he's going to be mad if i do
this
no he's like he wants he's um there's a
uh i once had to take this meditation
class to rewire my brain
of my attachment style and the uh
uh george haas the meditation to not be
jealous and codependent in a
relationship
is i love you keep going as a way to
like
support your partner like i love you
keep going like like
yeah thrive like yeah in a relationship
the idea isn't to
hold each other back and get stuck and
yep and benefit the other person go
thrive and then i love you keep going
keep thriving keep i love that and so
he's encourages
oh god that's him illicit shit yep yeah
see that is like yep that's him times a
million that's what we need
yep never once oh don't show your titty
he's like flop him out there you know
like
he you know get that check you know
okay so he's a pimp got it okay so he's
emotionally abusive he's using you he's
exploited
we'll talk about this in a way so no the
fir so i do a td calendar you know that
yeah i brought you one
i know i didn't i'm gonna i got a
package for you your tits are of i mean
one of the uh national landmarks
well one of the great wonders of the
world to the people that are listening
that don't know
um i've got some big saggy granny
titties
and i feel like most women do and
they're so like
you know like and i've never been
pregnant i don't have kids you know what
i mean like but it looks like i have
and um people want to cover them and i'm
like
who gives a fuck just flasher saggy
titty so
that's not the point um but how do you
we didn't even finish how do they
like how do you what is what bra do you
wear
i would say half the time i only wear
one okay honest forgotten and i feel
like
you know that lady in walmart
that's me with the no bra that's walking
around you're like oh damn she's putting
on a bra that's me
and um yeah so um
yeah i don't know this bra is from
walmart and uh what size is it
you don't i don't even know if you're
well i feel like
my bras are different sizes if there's
not one size if you were
different brands or different sizes like
if you were going to go to a website
right now and buy some
bra what bra would you buy i would i
would say i'm probably a like
42 g or h
g or h because that's the size of the
cup yeah
yep and then when were you this size
so i feel like i feel like maybe like
five years ago i gained some weight and
the tits got much bigger
before that um like when did you first
get boobs
oh oh elementary school you were like
boobs i'm not kidding yeah
because it really defines you as a
person yeah because i didn't have boobs
really when i was
no these are new oh yeah these are these
yeah we've gone through a couple
a couple doctors on this one these are
only two my
boobs are like three okay which is why
if a guy feels me up i'm like you're a
pedophile
they're young those are too young for
you um
no i remember being like in fifth grade
fourth or fifth grade and having like a
c cup and you had to wear bra
mm-hmm i hated that
it's traumatizing yes like i had i had a
my best friend in middle school uh
had to get a breast reduction i remember
she had to leave school and get a breast
she had such giant boobs and it was like
embarrassing and she had back problems
it was like a whole thing and it's like
oh yeah it's one of those things where
it's like the girls are like oh you have
big boobs your
life is so hard yeah i was like so flat
chested you know it is a big deal
yeah it is i was the first girl in the
school wearing bras
you know basketball everybody was
running regular and i was
you know that was embarrassing i run
like this you know like that was
embarrassing
literally i'd run like this
hated it but no the first so this is
like the third or fourth calendar i've
done
and the first two were kind of like sexy
like i do
i do it as trailer trash tammy and it's
basically
i don't mind if chicks do hot calendars
i think it's great girl gets your money
but it was my way of kind of making fun
of it yeah you know yeah
and the first two did not show nipple or
anything
and then um the last one i thought
i'm going full titty why not yeah why
not
and i didn't even ask greg why would i
ask gray they're my titties you know
type of thing
and uh so i showed him the counter and
he's like oh
you went full tit and i'm like yeah you
like he's like i love it
yeah so you know like just there's no
there's no
jealousy he he lets me um be me and like
you said like
go off and throt like he's very much
like when i
i quit my nine to five almost four years
ago
and we had just bought a house in
california
which you know expensive as hell yeah
san diego um
yeah i wasn't making a ton of money he
was doing okay
and um so we our rent to mortgage had
doubled
and we had been in the house maybe a
month and i woke up one morning and went
to work and on my way to work i thought
i'm quitting i'm quitting
didn't even talk to him about it nothing
and what was this job
i was working at qualcomm so my
husband's an engineer at qualcomm
and um so i was working like like as an
engineer assistant like testing parts
for them and shit like whatever
i watch netflix all day and um
yeah and uh i went and put in my two
weeks and i was like holy shit
and i called him and i was like babe and
he was like yeah i go i just put in my
two weeks notice
and i literally thought he's gonna say
we just bought like we just bought
i wasn't making any money on social
media and he goes
i thought he was gonna say we just
bought a house like go tell him you want
your job back you know blah blah blah
and he goes that's great now you can do
this full time now you can put
everything into what you want to do your
dream
yeah come on yeah
and i started making money like within a
month or two and i'd already been doing
it
four years five almost five years
without making a dime
and once once i like put everything into
it and everything i started making money
that's amazing so i think they got that
emotional support
yeah yeah and i think that's it you know
like listen he gets on my fucking nerves
dude
oh 15 years oh god to the point where
like i travel a lot
especially like before pandemic and
people message you sleep in the same bed
yeah see i i can't i can't
no nexus i i cannot sleep that is my
mate i cannot
sleep next to someone well we have a
california king and we have two separate
blankets i ain't sharing a blanket with
him no
that's that's what get a separate
blanket why the heat
oh god everything i don't don't touch me
i want my own i don't have to worry
about pulling the blanket no that's
i my sleeping i am like a corpse when i
want to be left alone
don't want to be touched it's a very
personal sleeping is a very private
experience for me
the idea of having someone else i i i
just cannot sleep next to another person
when i'm like on a plane
and people are just like conk out next
to i'm like you're literally at your
most vulnerable
next to this stranger wow like just
falling asleep i cannot fall asleep but
what about human being but you said
stranger what about someone that you're
with
or that you love yeah still but yeah
because you're there and then i'm like
oh
you keep from hey did you do that thing
like then i have to like talk to you
i can't just lay there and not be like
okay like yeah it's just
my i can't be next to a person i'm in a
relationship with and not be
thinking about their needs oh or like or
okay or or judging them or getting
annoyed by them yeah
see that's i think that's okay it's
called mental illness yeah
okay okay no i don't judge my aunt and
uncle sleep in separate rooms and
they're like
they have like the best relationship and
i think they still fuck you know yes
so but it's like i don't judge if you
you got to do what's come you know you
feel like
dude what is what what am i in for in
terms of when i get married
sex is just oh honey
oh honey it's true what they say
what oh getting oh my god
me getting laid is like you know how
like it's the the woman never wants to
have sex and the man
that's like the stereotype yeah it's
opposite friends never like that
he's like i'm tired i'm like really
you're tired
that's the only thing we fight about oh
i get so mad
yeah that's about it that's all we fight
about sex yeah and we don't even fight
but i'm always like you
dumbass and i like slam the door do you
think uh
does are guys allowed to jerk off when
they're in a relationship
or watch porn
okay i would okay i wouldn't be upset
but
i want to be taken care of first yeah
okay there you go
you fuck me first you take care of me
first now if you're doing that
instead of me
bitch bitch bitch bitch we're going to
have
problems it needs to be in addition to
not in lieu of thank you
thank you um all you want go
after yeah i get mine you can go watch
whatever porn you want exactly
just don't watch it at 4pm at work and
then come home and
agree have no cum left agree and i know
a lot of chicks a lot of chicks have a
problem with that
you know i i rub i rub some out all the
time really
oh yeah use sex toys oh yeah i've never
used a sex toy i'm
we just talked about this on the podcast
oh my god i don't even know like i've
just never
done it i don't know if i'm just i'm not
i'm
coordinated in shock right now yeah like
never used one never
literally never tried one is that like
weird
yeah really yeah i'm so i grew up
without money sorry bitch
i got money to throw around i got my
first
i grew up in a trailer house with holes
in the floor and i still managed to get
a vibrator at 20.
i think i was 20 years old and it was
live it was like
you know how like when was that like i
would say 2000.
they were like beige it's just like a
baby i got one of the little bullets
it looks like a little it looks like a
little bullet ipod like yeah
i love the idea of just like the analog
vibrators
um i honestly think i remember it was
like 2007 dude
and you know how like something happens
to you
and the heavens part
and you hear angels like that's what it
was like for me and i was like
what the fuck did i just open
here what wait was it the bullet thing
yeah
little vibrating bullet you just put on
your clit just put it there
just put it there that's all you got to
do
ain't going to do nothing dude
please try one for me why i i've like
like this is
i mean maybe i can go off
antidepressants and i've just never done
it i've never
never gone into the sex toy oh
i don't go crazy i don't do like clamps
and anal beads and shit i just you know
i don't even know
no no i don't do that but like and some
dudes get like well
you know women they get mad because
they're like how can we compete with
that huh
dude i can still you can still make me
nut
relax okay yeah it's not yeah but it's
all
it's always guys that like want to float
the idea of a threesome
but the idea of a sex toy is like how
dare you it's like well you wanted a
human person in here with us
yeah and you're threatened by this piece
of plastic i like that made it uh
probably made it a wet market yep yep
exactly um you follow nine porn stars on
instagram
yet i'm not allowed to have one little
like pocket
whatever yeah clit vibrator oh if greg
ever dude i keep my mind stays on my bed
i don't even put it down in the drawing
when it stays right on top greg walks by
it every day he don't give a shit
really oh yeah that's amazing oh yeah
oh if he had a problem with me oh
that'd be that'd be my number one i'd be
like bro
is he like a having sex in public person
no
he is that i think that's a thing he is
so vanilla i love oh that's so
that is hot to me that's hot to me
really guy that just wants to fuck
old-fashioned old-fashioned
yeah lord of the fly style fucking
old-fashioned
well just nothing crazy like when
there's props get involved
i'm like why am i hanging from hooks
yeah no no no no yeah i just
just fuck me yeah that's it that's what
he wants to do like
but so he probably didn't grow up on a
lot of porn
maybe um no i don't i don't know his
family was real no not real religious
but his dad
his grandfather was a preacher okay yeah
yeah yeah
but like i remember in college i tried
have you heard of this so he's consumed
with shame that's why he's yeah
yeah he's just honestly consumed with
shame and guilt yep right right right
right does he cry
that's why he cries when he comes he's
very yeah that's
i um one time we tried a penis ring have
you ever heard of those
the cock ring that keeps your dick hard
well it's like a little
ring and on the end of it is a clit rub
rubber so it's to him with a cock ring
i don't know where i got this dude
someone gave it to me i was like we're
using it
dude i put it on him and he like freaked
the fuck out i was like
like literally was like it's a vibrating
ring it's like a just a little
latex ring and there's like a little
thing on the end of it dick ring did i
just google dick ring
maybe like vibrating decorating you're
about to fuck up my algorithm majorly
the ads i'm about to get yes penis rings
that love honey how are they not a
sponsor
for you podcast love honey get extra
thick silicone cock ring set
this is a big business jesus does it
have a little
thing on the end of it what kind of
thing because there's cock rings
and then there's like this is a like
these are like rings that are oh that's
something
wait okay yeah yeah yeah yep and then
that vibrates
and so you put it right charge it i like
i i already can't even like the number
of chargers i have in my house like this
feels like a lot of
logistics no dude ever since then he
won't let me
go near him with you it was just like no
more of your no more nothing correct
yeah no more nothing no more electronics
on my genitals anything
no he was not having it he's very
vanilla
is this a shock collar yeah yeah that
oh his little i'll never forget his
little penis just went do you get
got scared buddy do you get in fights
no you never fight because i'm trying to
figure out if
marriages healthy relationships if it
takes work
and you gotta fight through it and you
gotta communicate and compromise or if
it should just
feel easy and you marry your best friend
and you shouldn't have conflict like
which is it
well our communication is popping
there's nothing that i won't say to him
we're on the same cell phone plan
there's nothing that if i'm like dude i
don't even want to say like if i if i'm
like
feeling something or whatever i tell him
there's nothing i won't say to him you
know
resentments zero
and um do we fight
no do we bicker yes i think there's a
different difference
they got to know the difference and the
language is important
yep and big differences when you go to
your friends and go like hey i'm
fighting with my guy
they're going to start hating your
friends yeah because you're saying
fighting when you say like oh we're just
bickering
like don't make it more dramatic than it
is yeah that's like a really fucking
important lesson
big yeah and his personality he's very
we're both
very strong and headstrong and he's
extreme
extrovert even more than me really so
it's
like this a lot i'm the one that shuts
my mouth
in the relationship i ever closed my
mouth yeah oh he
no no no so it's just easier for me to
just you know bite my tongue
and walk off that is so that is like the
that is for everything in life just bite
your fucking tongue i could say the bang
i've got a banger in here
i could totally destroy you i could
destroy your
sense of self i could destroy the way
you
view yourself and your entire family
frankly like when you go home and you
like
see like the dysfunctional fucked up
shit that your person's in and they
think it's normal and you're like i
could fucking point out some shit right
now yeah
that would dismantle your entire mental
house of cards
could ruin your life it could literally
ruin your concept
you would go into an existential crisis
but i'm not but i'm not gonna
mm-hmm i'm not gonna that's the hardest
thing that's power
yeah that's fucking yes that's success
yes that's that's maturity mm-hmm being
like
yes i'm gonna let you have this one
yep and he doesn't have that because
it's like not worth it yeah exactly it's
not worth it and we're
because that's my thing is whenever you
start like fighting with like are we
gonna break up or not
yeah i'm saying like what are we
fighting for what's the
like um verdict here we know the ver if
the verdict is we're staying together we
know the outcome is going to be
just work through it whatever yeah i
have um uh
uh my uh friend um ethan sandler
uh uh used to write a great comedy
writer
he has been with his uh wife for you
know 30 years now or something and
when they start fighting he'll just like
fart and just try to make her laugh
because it's just like what are we doing
like it's good and um
i've tried to start doing that in fights
i can fart on command
really no okay
i can't either no
okay we add that to the list of things
we need to buy button you know how
people say that like oh if you're in a
if you're in a fight or in a you know if
you're bickering
just do something or take off your
clothes whatever
who says that i've heard you've never
heard that oh god i've heard that
oh if you're if you're in a if you're
fighting just
take off your shirt caroline you're
talking to caroline brian
dude i've heard that so many times or do
this or like you said it's far whatever
when i'm bickering motherfucker i'm
bickering
i'm not doing nothing else whoa okay
okay
i'm pissed okay so if if so you're not
the person to try to make laugh in a
fight
no no when you're mad you're mad oh and
oh and he knows that he'll he'll be like
he'll start laughing and go you're mad
that i think people don't understand
like you'll get oh like
feelings aren't facts like don't make
temporary decisions or don't
make permanent decisions based on
temporary feelings like
this is temporary like you guys have an
idea like you know
this is gonna this is ephemeral and it's
gonna pass oh yeah
for sure whereas like i feel like in
relationships i'm like it's over
like every fight is like ah really out
of here
yeah now like it's like the end of the
world
oh no it's just a part of it yeah
um no and for me i think time apart
for me yeah is is important he
wants to be stuck up my ass 24 7. oh
he's obsessed with you
and i can't do that
so like that's why i like to travel
without him uh-huh
and it's good to miss so you've been
together so long yeah you got it yeah
breather yeah and um i travel a lot
right but no people but he's getting so
famous that you leave him and he's like
he's your kevin fetterline
oh shit done done
but no people be like don't you miss
greg i'm like no
i don't i've been with him for i don't
man and he'll he'll kind of look at me
like
i'm like babe i didn't i love you i'm
glad i'm back now you know so
yeah we have a good we have a really
good i want to ask you
just in terms of like your relationship
with hollywood like
you know you are like on the trajectory
of someone that
before the pandemic and maybe before
like podcasting
i would have been like oh she's about to
be the thing
she's about to be the thing you know
what
now with the it's it it's happening at
such a weird time yeah
in like in what is you and i know
there's such an adversarial relationship
with
television hollywood and comedy and
specials like what do you
want and what is your relationship to
hollywood
um hollywood is such a gross word it's
such a pejorative term
yeah you said hollywood i'm like huh
hollywood hollywood hollywood
um okay i if i
don't ever do anything else than what
i'm doing right now
oh i'm good you're having the most fun
like i literally look at you i'm like
she's having
the most fucking fun which is why she's
so fucking happy i'm
i almost want to just be like stay there
don't don't cross over to the other side
there's nothing you're gonna you're
gonna get uh
they're gonna come and they're gonna i
know that's what everybody's telling you
but but yeah there's a way to do it
well and let's just talk through it it's
a way to do it right
yeah um yeah
you know it but if things happen if you
know whatever
if things take off that's great would
you want to do a tv show
yeah but if it doesn't happen i'm not
going to be like oh yeah but
it's also it's like you know and i think
this is like more a question for the
for fans like do you want to see us
doing television or do you want to just
hear us talk like it's it's this weird
thing where
you know um we have to just make a
decision of
what we enjoy doing yeah also and then
see what the fans want because a lot of
times like people get
a super famous comedian and then goes a
tv show and they're playing a
firefighter it's like no i liked him as
a comedian why does he now have to be a
firefighter and a bad marriage i had to
watch him do stand up like why are you
putting him in this shitty sitcom where
he's now pretending to be a
you know you have a fake job it's you
know it would have to be
so like tosh.0 i feel like is an example
of something that was done
well in terms of taking what makes a
comedian
great and funny getting the fuck out of
their way giving them a platform
and money to get to their audience yeah
that's that's when
tv does it right yeah you know it
doesn't always have to destroy you
right right i think for me i would
more so in the forefront of my mind it
would be like what the fans want over
what i want
yeah always no doubt they're they're the
customer they're the yes
no doubt which is why i do stand up as
trailers
um which is why i do stand up as trailer
trash tammy because
when the first three or four shows i did
i did them as chelsea
and just to see if i could do it you
know what i mean yeah
and i did it they went well um
was great i was like okay i can do it
now denim is tammy i'm like this is what
people want to see
this is what so it's the same material
it's it's material from my life as
chelsea
just told as tammy and tammy is who is
tammy
oh god tammy oh
trailer trash tammy she's a badass bitch
she's a man eater she's thinks she's the
most gorgeous
thing in the world and she'll beat your
ass at the same time for looking at her
wrong
and is she and so lovable how
my my hero my hero
yeah the only reason i have any
self-esteem uh
and how did this like does this would
you describe it as like an alter ego
or like a character or like both
your best self both it's a character but
it's weird because i feel like
she is me as well like
constantly my husband and my sisters
i'll say something i'll do something
like whoa okay tammy like if she tammy
came out yeah she's in there
we all we all have different sides of us
in us
and yeah you know right that's all it is
so i took you've seen the movie monster
with charlie's theron yeah
i took the aesthetic i raped
someone in the 80s what that's a weird
thing to admit
you know that movie monster yeah i raped
someone too yeah
um so i took just the hair the
mannerisms of that you know what i mean
yeah
um and then but in terms of the
character she's part of
every woman i know growing up in
oklahoma
and then she's part of me it's weird so
she has a character but
most definitely an alter ego benton's
here
hey sugar benton oh
i see i see he dressed up
the best you look great are you wearing
a marilyn manson t-shirt
yeah very problematic and betty white
she doesn't give a fuck oh that's true
i know i didn't say anything because i'm
not gonna
i wasn't thinking i'm getting canceled
no you'll just get those dms why are you
still following me i don't know because
oh i i i was
i just bought this for betty white dude
but yeah i didn't think about it
rolling on her oh yeah okay well we
we're still rolling
okay because i do want though the moment
you realize you're wearing a maryland
please don't cancel me
i didn't realize i'm just a betty white
fan dude
please don't cancel me i knew this would
be the day i get canceled
i knew it'd be the day wait did you just
like not put it together that you're
wearing marilyn manson no
you said i would like to distance myself
from hot topic i had no clue
and i don't even let i don't even i
bought this for i thought it was cool
it's like a photoshop
i just put it on not thinking cancel so
you think that's a
you think that's a betty white shirt
it's not a buddy white shirt here
i'm covering him there we go
that could be anyone in a corset that
could be anyone
the fact is i'm not gonna move you've
been wearing a marilyn manson shirt
this is so funny so you you
knew and you didn't say that before but
i was like i'm not we could so
i brought a different shirt to wear
millennial i brought it right up i said
excuse me
i saw it and i was like look i'm not
gonna tell people what they can and
can't wear
basically no you should have been live
ma'am ma'am
i brought a different shirt she goes oh
i love your shirt i go i'll wear it
i saw i clocked it and i was like ah
maybe she hasn't seen that
because i'm in la and i'm like maybe
this is just la news maybe it's only
news that i've seen
and i you know yeah i had to put all
mine in my bottom drawer i was like all
these fucking shirts all the yeah
and then josh wheaton i was like good
lord i know
i like that because but but the fact
that
he's like going through getting dragged
on the internet this week and you're
wearing it this week it's almost like
i thought you were like just leaning in
on it no i think you're doubling down
but i wasn't thinking like i'm not
throwing this shirt away i thought you
were trying to get betty in trouble see
she hung out with her yeah yes
you're trying you're canceling betty
white right now that's what you're doing
betty white endorsed marilyn manson
all that behavior she gave him the idea
but it's like
that's so funny all the things that i've
had to throw away because
uh the people got canceled um
i was going through my bookshelves and
it was like even like it was like fuck i
had like a
play like the iceman cometh is a play
kevin spacey played it on broadway and
so for when i
recently like bought the book five years
ago again he's like on the cover you
know how they'll put
the celebrity that on the cover of a new
issue yeah in the book
and i'm like fuck kevin spacey well i
have to throw this i got in trouble for
watching palmer
justin timberlake's in it and they're
like what about brittany and i was like
first of all let me just tell you a
secret
this little story about this little gay
southern child i'm not about to cancel
the whole movie because justin bieber's
in it
timberlake dude you'll get
you'll get canceled for acknowledging
someone that's canceled
but here's the thing are you who's who's
been
who's actually been besides like real
allegations real
are people really getting canceled
here's what i'm thinking or is it just
attention
what's your what's your definition of
cancer because to me it's right if
you're if your agency drops you and all
these things are happening like that's
pretty natural
and you don't work again you're
canceling that's cancelled but i think
i think i do think comedians we are a
little histrionic about we're like we
see two negative comments and we're like
they're cancelling me
if you have to make a patreon cancelled
yeah
oh my god oh damn is that kind of is the
litmus test if you get banned from
patreon i don't know what to tell you
i don't know what to tell you you're
just like out there on twitch
like doing the damn thing twitch
canceling i don't i have no idea
um but i uh yeah i don't like do you
have to think about that
like i don't i don't know i mean
i think about it a little bit but i
don't do i don't do
shit or say shit to get canceled so
i don't know what i'm worried about you
know what i mean like i don't i don't
know
i'm not you don't think about it no but
i'm always like oh god like they're
cancelling some
well and there's some bravery like
comedians our job is to be brave
that's our job our job is to come out
and be brave and say the thing no one
else will say and
have the take that no one else even if
we're wrong
that's the other thing our job is kind
of to be wrong and
i i've been struggling a lot with
podcasting and it's just in general
right now because it's like
i like to have space to be wrong and
have difficult conversations
and say the wrong thing and do the wrong
thing and think the wrong thing and then
someone tell me i'm wrong and then learn
from it
but we can't learn in public anymore no
these people
say you're ignorant yeah you have to
have learned off camera
and just all of a sudden be up to date
on everything all the time
and um you know i like to be sloppy and
messy and make mistakes not only that
but also your your
your past self had to also be really on
top of it you also could make mistakes
when you were 16 or 17 or 19 or
it's like i feel like i've been on thin
ice like just like my whole life
you know and i i feel like now more than
ever i just i feel like i'm on thin ice
as a comedian and that's
we're the opposite we're the ones that
are supposed to come out and just say
all the offensive shit
we don't mean it but i do feel like
you're inspiring me to stop
living in this like i have fear for the
first time in my life as a
as a comic the whole point of being you
have to be fearless that's the common
denominator
delusional confidence fearlessness i'm
going to come out
and now i'm like uh me when i try
clothes on
yeah but you seem almost uncancelable
because your comedy is very eu-centric
it's not really about other people true
trailer chess tammy it's just it's also
so like
she's so relatable
she's everyone knows someone like
everyone's got that one
she's not southern you know someone i
know someone like that
yeah and it's also so like unapologetic
it's so like therapeutic
so unapologetically sexual yeah it's
just like the it's so like
yeah she's like my hero yeah thank you
trailer chess tammy is who i am in
uh therapy to become and who i might be
in plastic surgery
yeah i want to get them titties off yes
then big old titties um
god that's so funny um but like do you
just say but because here's the thing if
you if you
do a tv show it's it depends
you either do a tv show people come to
you and they're like what do you want to
do you get
you get paired with someone basically
like a show runner
and my fear would be that someone's like
here come
only be trailer tammy and we're gonna do
this thing where we like
make fun of the south and it's like nope
no that's not what we're doing here no
um i feel like
i've already been i've been thinking a
lot about this if i were to do a tami
show
um if um if they wanted to change
anything about her or anything
i'd just rather not do one dude that's
it no i'm not doing it that's it
i'll just keep doing the internet thing
they i mean i get calls all the time
they're like
this this show worked really well in
england
i'm going to make up a fake name to not
tell you what the real show was named
um betty and that would they want to do
it in america i'm like
what was the show it was oh based on
this comedian named betty she was huge
in edinburgh film festival and now she's
here so now let's do one here
uh with a different person who's like no
no the essence of the person is why that
show
yeah you can't recast someone else to
live their experience like
fleabag that was like her experience you
can't just
cast someone else right does not make
sense
no does not make sense um so yeah i just
i just keep doing what i'm doing on the
internet if that was the case
yeah yeah i'd want i'd want control over
definitely the character and you know i
wouldn't want to do a show
whether it was a a scripted show or
or whatever type of show it was no if
someone wrote something that
tammy wouldn't say i'm not saying it
what would you what do you watch
oh i just started watching shit's creek
yeah just now
just now i'm on season two oh yeah i
love it
i watch a lot of um crime shit
i don't watch a whole lot i have a
theory about this
test me on this okay i have a th
i have a theory that this is a
southern thing okay am i wrong crimes
what crime
crimes well that happened a lot
everywhere i just mean i just mean like
i
all my f like growing up in a rural when
you're in a rural area
it's like our brain's way of like doing
research on like what might happen well
i
i think i think southern people
definitely like my family watched it and
my mom would be like my mom's even
southern she's from the north but
she would watch and she's like see in
new york that's what happened yeah
it becomes in the big city to be like
aren't you happy you live here in the
middle of nowhere
because look what happens there they
sell kids together my mom used to tell
me that the sewer grates that the rain
runs into those grades
where they kept bad kids yeah
oh my gosh our parents told us to keep
us obedient as i mean
child abuse looking back dude my grandma
used to if she's to tell us she was
gonna there was a creek in our
backyard back property that she was
going to take us out there and shoot us
i'm not kidding my mom used to tell me
chucky but come get me if i was bad
chucky the killer my mom used to tell me
that the ice cream truck played music
when it was out of ice cream
oh damn
damn that's a good ice cream truck where
you lived wow
we had to drive an hour away to get a
soft start from mcdonald's
yes yes ice cream truck oh my god how
many went to walmart after prom
what a luxury how many people were in
your town growing up
i graduated with 12 people in the town
few hundred i would say do you go back
over i do
like do we have a do you get the key to
the city i mean oh god they think i'm
brad pitt are we gonna
do they call you hollywood hi hallelujah
it's the weirdest yeah
like are they no my aunt calls me that
hollywood yeah
um but yeah it is weird going back
i'll i'll say that are you like the
honorary governor
no oh my god no no where i'm from
and i don't know if you had this in your
high school if someone like
succeeded in any way you got your own
like you know you're walking in the
halls
and they're like there's like the glass
cases yeah you've got like your head
shot
and like yeah you don't want to talk i
could live or die in my hometown they
wouldn't care
but they do do that we have we had a guy
that played a one game of basketball
professionally and he might as well run
the stage
yes that's right his pictures are
everywhere the one picture he took he
took one picture
and it's it's side by side like like
wallpaper
let me tell you something oh we have to
cut this part out because his don't give
him
yeah his mom was my speech teacher
she died in a tornado okay okay this is
it
this is so much i had to write her an
apology letter one time this is why
benson can't be here for full interviews
because he just
says things that are just like well now
that's its own podcast
yeah that's its own six episodes in the
first grade she was my teacher
and i didn't like i was like i had this
like we had like you know those book
fairs
yep so i went i bought this super long
pencil from the oh you bought something
from the book fair
one thing a pencil and i was like i kept
doing like this with it like it was a
wand and when she walked by it like it
like picked her skirt up
and she thought that i picked her skirt
up on purpose and i couldn't say i
didn't because i was doing this
i was like yeah i did and i had to write
her an apology i'd write her i'm sorry a
hundred thousand times and then she died
a tornado
wouldn't mean she died in a tornado i
mean a tornado came and killed her
oh how was she that's taking her up into
the air
hey that's rare that's rare that's a
once in a lifetime no not
really that is a serendipitous event
we've been devastated by tornadoes
multiple times
but to be sucked up by one that's rare
that's my frustration i mean
it's a cool way to tie i mean how do you
die if you die in a turn do you
suffocate or do you you probably get hit
by
a shit strap yep you get hit by the
uh metal and stuff other people yeah i
think it takes your breath away
no yeah like what happens i don't know
she died because she died what's the
cause of death home's crush
this is the kind of stuff i i i lose
sleep hold up they said well tornado got
her and they drove away probably
it got up and then fell down we weren't
there we were hiding in bitches i know
either her house crushed on her yeah she
was a wicket oh see this is getting bad
this is what i'm saying bentonville say
something i'm just gonna hear this and
be like that little son of a please
don't cut any of this
no way trust me the other day he's like
yeah when i was a kid and i was riding
in a go-kart and a
groundhog jumped in the go-kart and i
crashed in the barn i'm like that story
needs more detail
yeah that's all that happened though but
here's the thing but nothing else
happened but you know how long i
screamed i wrecked we got the go-kart
but you know how like stories over time
you you shorten them up because you told
them so many times
so i'm like i feel like he's shortening
the story because he's told somebody
that's not the real story
yeah like let's back up i want to know
how you felt i want to know what
actually
happened because you're and then but him
him like just
generalizing uh is what actually
happened it's always shocking
that's what i was told they just said
she died in a tornado and the next day
went to school she wasn't there
oh man but i was that's a nasty death
that was really traumatic that's a nasty
death by them thinking i picked your
skirt up that's the main part of the
story to me i was like oh that is not a
good thing to do
yeah did you like it did you enjoy it i
didn't even do it on purpose it was an
accident and then i just had to be like
okay and it probably went up to like her
knee or something
i couldn't imagine i had that i was like
fishing it up or anything they had it
out for you though she really
did not enjoy it did they which is a
good point to make good things she made
that she was your speech instructor
what's she therapist because i said my s
is different
yeah different was she an old lady um
i was in the first grade so to me yes
yeah she was probably 28.
yeah like totally she's my older than
that do you um uh
do you ever uh find yourself or have you
i've talked about this with theo before
like
with an accent do you ever like up it or
down it
in a conversation i mean we all talk
differently to people based on who we're
talking to yeah we all like i mean if i
want someone to take me here so i'm like
hey guys how's every like i i like i
have different voices i mean
my voice is trapped in constant puberty
so i don't even know
i have no control over it i'm just
curious because i just
having talked to theo about this and
just about like the um
he's like i don't feel like i can be
authentic or in everywhere you know
oh i never thought about that i don't
think but i don't know
when i'm around people that are southern
i start the fact that i'm not fully
southern right now i'm really so hot
i yeah it's like contagious california i
don't get asked at my voice at all
really but when i used to live
back in in tennessee they'd be like do
you have aids oh
oh dang i noticed your accent
yeah you have a strong accent yeah for
sure yeah yeah
now greg my husband he's embarrassed i'm
just trying to move past that
i
[Laughter]
um greg oh he embarrasses the hell out
of me
he's the type of person if he's talking
to anyone with an accent
foreign accent it does not matter he
starts speaking
yes and i'm like you're and after he's
talking i'm like what the f
that is like what are you talking about
i go dude
that was you you were mimicking him you
were talking to an asian person you
started bowing
it was weird i said bye what's wrong
babe whenever i
talk to someone who's super southern and
i start getting super southern i'm like
you must think everyone's southern
because they turn southern when they
talk to you
like you don't even have an accurate
representation of what the world is like
yeah
because we catch your southern yeah i
find that in california when you do
something that's like very
normal in like the south like holding a
door open for someone or just manners
that people get like are sho i held the
doorpoint for the city at starbucks one
time and she literally stopped and
looked at me and i was like
did you want to go and she's like what
are you doing i'm holding the door open
and she was like it's creepy
thank you southern yeah southern manners
is now
creepy or problematic so
i in virginia i i
live in rhode island virginia my aunts
live with my aunts yes ma'am no ma'am
yeah to everyone if you didn't say yes
ma'am no ma'am
you gotta pinch on the back of your neck
or your ear when you're
dragged out of the store yes something
yeah yeah or we'd get a what
what what was that what was that yeah
say it again so um
uh yes ma'am no ma'am and it's so
programmed into my brain
and now yes ma'am no ma'am i'm like
accidentally misgendering someone
like and i and i like i did it at a i
was somewhere and i was like yes ma'am
no ma'am or i said uh no sir or
something and
the person was like man i was like oh my
god like that was literally it's just
i was trying to do manners and i i i
made a boo-boo that's why i called
everyone girl yes girl yes girl
you heard your girl yeah yeah sugar you
ever caught a straight guy girl
triggered well i called traumatic men
i'll say no ma'am to greg
yeah ma'am yeah it's so funny he gets so
mad
he gets so mad but like where i'm from i
don't know if
you guys did this like if you're driving
down the road
and i did notice this when i moved to
california when you're driving down the
road
you wave yes everybody you hate it or
not
you wait if you know them if you don't
know them you wave you both wave to each
other
and so when i first moved out here what
did people you know i got
so i'm like they're not waiting just no
nobody waves
no no waving you know what you're doing
we're driving yeah you know
i'm like i'm driving that means i'm
texting also yeah whenever you drive
here like when you drive back in the
south it's like you kind of like you're
very leisurely about like you can you
can go go ahead and go yeah here it's
like
you better fight to merge yeah it is a
full-on fight
yes you have to put your head out the
window
none of you have anywhere to be clearly
you're out in the middle of the day with
me so what do you do
there's such a there's such a um uh
you know it's such a like cheesy like
you said a thing
but it's like it is really like small
towns like we're all in this together
like i
i'm gonna see you at the grocery store
next week like i can't afford to have
bad blood with
every like it's like we're all in this
together
whereas here it's like when people like
cut me off i'm like dude
i could run into you tomorrow like i see
you why would you do be an asshole to me
i will say on the flip side california
you guys are in it together on on
maybe maybe more important things than
sometimes the south is sometimes we get
a little
we sometimes we're in our own little
civil wars
yeah yeah i mean it is interesting like
i mean the question is for me it's like
taking all the like positives of the
small town mentality and keeping them
you know uh with you and not letting it
get
adulterated by not letting people make
you mean
yeah getting people like keeping that
like i still am like
yeah honesty yeah that's so interesting
and then get rid of like you know
pills yes take the
take what you like that's anywhere you
live anywhere take what you like and
leave the rest
yep um any more uh relationship advice
because
uh it's very rare that we have someone
who's in a successful relationship on
the show well who knows how long that's
gonna last yeah i
i honestly with your fame i hope i hope
you just get so famous
that you start dating chris evans and
greg
lost nightmare lawsuit laura wasser was
just on we can hook you up with the
biggest the biggest celebrity lawyer on
the planet
statistically you know who knows what's
gonna happen yes
um no that's really it uh uh honestly
i think i think we just lucked out i
know that sounds so i i really do you
and your guy
yeah yeah i think we just lucked out
because like i said i could not be with
someone that was
had a problem with what i did or had a
problem with how i was with my friends
because he didn't because this is what's
so interesting to me
he didn't sign up for a famous wife
you know what i mean like there's
certain uh
you know for me like like i i i don't
everyone knows that i'm very dysmorphic
about i
i'm always surprised when anyone
recognizes me i don't think of myself as
like famous but
but i now understand that someone that's
dating me
knows what they're getting into and
there's a little bit of a like
why would you want to be with someone
who's in the public eye like and i and
that's
there's a little paranoia there but i
was in a relationship with someone who
changed careers like kind of like a year
and a half in and it was
i was like this isn't what i wanted like
this is not what i thought because
what you do for living is what you talk
about every night what you complain
about
all the time like i you have to your
partner has to hear about what you do
all day every day
yeah and what i signed up to hear about
was different i know it's weird it
sounds great and it made it weird
because it was my business and i was
like i was like oh i don't want to
talk about my all i do is work and now
my
one off time with you now you're talking
about your work which is also my work
and now
everything feels like work all the time
damn so it's like
so i was just interested because i was
like if you change your career
while you're with the person and all of
a sudden he's like i kind of signed up
for like
this and now i got this like he's been
so great with the transition yeah that
it has not been an issue yet it's crazy
at all because you know like checks are
clearing he doesn't give a fuck
exactly honestly exactly i mean if yeah
if you were getting paid i'm sure you
had some problems
yeah if you were just doing it for the
love right no
uh yeah cause i you know i've been
working fast food when we got together
yeah so that's never been brought up i
have no idea what he thinks about that
i have no clue and she said i don't care
he's just proud of you
yeah not competitive with you yeah this
is so telling about the kind of people
that i date
like so he's not like trying to get in
your videos
and he doesn't like oh no okay
no no he's just excited when he can quit
his job i mean he could quit now
but he's very like he's the type of
person that he has to be
working and doing something yeah you
know so he's like i'm not what would i
do if i quit you know do you feel on
social media this like hustle to put
stuff out like how do you
like i think everyone's kind of
struggling right now with like how much
do i how present do i need to be
to feel like is it always in the back of
your mind like i should post this i
should record this
oh yes and no like i would rather put
out
a good video than a bunch of mediocre
videos
so and people are they're always like
you know we need
another video we need a more video i'm
like i don't have any ideas right it's
also like the reason you like it is
because you
i left you wanting more yeah yeah i mean
yeah good friends will let you take a
break
yeah if they really care about you
they're going to want you to have it you
need a moment
yeah and you don't see beyonce tap
dancing every day do you like
literally she will beyonce and donald
glover do it right they go away
yeah go i'm gonna i'm gonna film this
when it's the best
and they come back with a masterpiece
you're like and then they just drop it
at like midnight
you're like yeah shit with no but i
didn't forget about you
yeah our fears are they gonna forget
about me what if i'm not in it they're
gonna
like oh no i don't think that no why
don't i have this brain
no um but i will think oh man i haven't
posted to instagram in a couple weeks so
i'll just you know take a selfie or
whatever
pop it up you know like i'll do stuff
like that but anger
yeah but no i don't i don't think no i
don't think about that
what's the most la thing you've done
that you would not really want to tell
people back home
i always think about like what's
something that they would be giving like
when you go home
will you have to change the way you like
can you wear your gucci shoes when you
go home yeah i haven't changed myself
yet i'm not about to do it then
i would say um okay
i still keep it pretty trashy i will say
that okay
um i would say i ordered subway
five days in a row yeah postman i bought
it
that's garbage i paid twenty seven
dollars
five days in a row for subway sandwiches
yes that is
like any of them and i felt like i was
home doesn't make you
um i keep it pretty trashy i did though
buy a
uh louis vuitton um bag and that was
weird for me
i bet oh going in the store well i'm not
a a
fashion person and i'm not no that's not
it i disagree with that
i think you are a fashion really yes wow
you're a fashion
i think you are literally if if tumblr
wasn't dead and gone you would be all
over it wow i think you are definitely
street fashion
hundred percent there's nothing about
this shirt i was like literally
thank you this is like bet this is
benton's area of expertise okay
whoa wrong okay okay okay sorry
well i don't feel like a fashion person
and i'm definitely not a
label or like expensive brand person but
i'm not
weird about people that are oh if you
want to go you know go get your shit
but i saw this bag on instagram and i
was like i screenshotted it and i had it
in my screenshots for like
almost a year okay exactly and i kept
thinking about this bag and i'm like i'm
not a louis vuitton type of person
and then i had gotten paid from
something i go
bitch i'm going louis vuitton and i went
and bought it and i i did feel really
weird
and then even carrying it i'm like oh my
god okay and like i posted a story and
somebody saw it in the back and i got a
bunch of dms
girl you got a louis vuitton i'm like oh
my god i was embarrassed i'm like
so sad why how come you don't deserve
that that's my thought process why don't
you deserve something you worked for
where does that come from i don't shame
it's just there's no would this what
what they what did they keep telling us
it was a couple class traders
yeah like the idea that like once you
get some success yeah yeah
but it's it's there is a shame around i
think
i i mean i'm like a two i'll order
something i'll return something that was
thirty dollars that's a nose i'm like
i'm still so preneurious with money i
think
you also buy you know 18 different types
of wrapping paper so that's you know
give or take
you could have me too but it's just like
it's just like if you kept that in your
if for a year you were thinking about
that who says you don't deserve that
that's just
yeah and also i'm the first person to go
like don't waste your money on dumb shit
but a purse is like
that is an investment in yourself and
it's you're carrying it with you
everywhere
and it's like we've all had the shitty
purses that we go through three a year
yeah this is one you're gonna have for
the rest of your life yeah and that's
what that's what i thought
and having nice things is not the same
as judging people for not having them
but if you're not going to debt if it's
not making your life manageable if your
kid's not starving you're going to
college because you're right like not
there's deading addiction is a very real
thing yes but that's not it's
we you don't need it but if you want it
around yeah yeah and yeah
that's weird and then my siblings yeah
two sisters
above uh older i'm the oldest yeah
interesting yeah and they were both like
what's this they're like you bought a
little like were you allowed to have
like
did you have lots of toys as a kid do
you have stuff no uh uh
stuff there was no stuff yeah stuff is
like a weird
yeah but um i forgot what was gonna say
you've built an identity outside of
objects so by something like that you're
just like i don't really need this to be
myself
yeah yeah oh my like if you want it go
for it my sis one of my sisters asked
she was like you went into the
louis vuitton store and bought and i was
like yeah and she was like what was that
like
i go honestly i'm not gonna lie it felt
like i was walking in target and
buying a i didn't care it wasn't even
like a security guard did try to drag me
out
aren't they so weird though they're all
like and do you want to start a profile
and you want us to call you and you're
like no i want you to
give me this one thing and leave me
alone yeah yeah no i
didn't i wasn't like it didn't feel any
different from me walking into a walmart
and buying a bag
yeah at all dolly apartment mentality i
can fly first class or plumb in the back
oh yeah wherever i am is right where i
belong so where's the purse
i literally feel like i never tried it's
still in the box i'm returning no
i i got it a little more than a year ago
and i carry it for a year and i
just changed to that person i don't know
why i just like to change it up
yeah i'm so interested like you should
get a gucci fanny pack
oh will it fit around my waist
my favorite things when super southern
people get a ton of money
what they spend their money on is so
funny to me cattle like just like
get lit yeah yes it'll be like a pimped
out tractor i'm like
like whenever i see someone like a
lawnmower with rims i know i'm like why
would you get a 401k can we save this
money
so what is like the biggest that is that
the biggest amount of money you spent
no i bought a i i've bought i bought two
cart two vintage cars this year okay
yeah i bought a 1978 lincoln town car
okay and it's badass what color is it
baby blue oh and then you make it blue
nope it's all original it's set in a
garage for 40 years
amazing the inside is baby blue
clouds it looks like it's like you're
sleeping it's like you're sitting on
clouds dude
dude oh my god that's like and i um
can you drive it it's my daily driver
except when i come to la okay
because i'm scared it's gonna like break
down you know yeah yeah yeah um
and then i bought a knight i think it's
a 1977
uh dodge ram charger truck it's a big
old
truck that won't let me have one because
you don't need it for anything what are
you doing
get a vintage we used to i just we used
to i guess i just
when i was a kid we'd sit in the back of
the truck with the dogs did you ever
swim in the back of the truck
yes we would no we'd put a um uh we'd
put
um what's it called um a tarp a tarp and
then put water in it yeah
mini pool we never did that weed so
dangerous we swam in a horse trough
yeah oh yeah that's what everybody
doesn't say i used to love sitting in a
horse straw
mm-hmm obsessed dead serious and now we
know
how colvin's you know yeah
horses is that what you want to put out
there got the method you want to send
you used to drink out of a hose oh yeah
my grandma used to
bathe this in the front yard literally
she would pour soap on it
and squirt us and that was our bathroom
we used to bathe in a creek
yeah sometimes i was like we used to
bathe in the muddy creek
yeah you get more dirty from your
washing experience
i know there's some stuff that just like
sticks with you that you're like no
that was still the best way to do it
like my aunt would uh
uh she'd blow dry her hair over a there
was a heating van on the floor
that i guess that's is that i guess yeah
yeah he
i've never encountered a vent that heat
comes out of yeah but i've never seen
that in california really
on the floor yeah in ver in roanoke
virginia there's a huge heating vent it
must have been this big
and we get out of the shower and you
just put your head over it and turn it
on and that's how we blow dry
true where are the vents in this house
the vents are in the ceiling
there's a wow in the in in virginia in
the south where i've got there's vents
on the floor yeah that's where my house
is at yeah
you can cook you can like do all i mean
one of my favorite things to do as a kid
is go to the church pit
i just love it the cherry pit tert pit
it's just a bunch of church like powered
up it's like a
a rock oh we call them the gravel pile
yeah so they're gravel we call it shirt
pit it's just it's just
a giant it's just a giant
go hang out the gravel pile yeah we used
to all the time and i would be obsessed
i was just like isn't it so cool there's
nothing there it's just rocks
literally a pile of rocks as big as this
well it's just that's why when like my
friends kids are on their phones all the
time it's like
we used to climb piles of rocks and fall
down them do you want to go back to that
is is snapchat really that bad for kids
do you want to go back to that
yeah so just like literally just jump
off suit like
old sewers you'd be like jump off that
thing like yeah my dad used to have me
track deer in the woods he would shoot a
deer and he would like
kind of not hit it perfectly on purpose
he'd be like well now go find that deer
i just have to walk around tracking the
blood till i found it oh
hell drag it back i was like what oh
hell it's great i think what an
adventure i thought i was like so cool
because benton just uh revealed okay
that's not crazy about deer hunting
knows that's normal
i mean no i now know how you're able to
drag me from a meeting to meeting
have practice this is literally
benjamin's job
dragon corpse oh my god and then he'd
make us skin the deer
and he'd be and he'd be like bite the
liver that's how you have you have to
bite the liver i knew that
i knew that why you ever popped it you
probably haven't never mind no
a dear stomach it's like a way to i
don't know
why do people do that it's like a it's
like a
it's like a rite of passage ritual yeah
it's like a oh yeah
i
feel a cantaloupe and make sure it's
right no you just skin it and before you
throw it away you just bite it and throw
it in the
box almost like a i don't know how to
explain it but i know what you're
talking about it's just like uh
you didn't really kill this year till
you bite its lift yeah you're you know
you're
yeah yeah it's a weird thing it feels
like it feels like a prank
i feel like you were abused
that's sending this out too like almost
every house has like a place where you
hang a deer to school
every like almost every house yeah
and here and you got the heads in there
yeah yeah
here it's pizza russia there's just
doctors babies in the back soccer
restaurants
um i hope you'll come back oh are we
done
well no i am
[Applause]
i'll come back i'll come back as tammy
if you want i will whatever you want is
me
i want to talk more about your boobs
let's do it what is your plan like are
you
like what's gonna happen when you have a
kid are you breastfeeding
well don't know if that's happening
we'll see i don't know if you want kids
no no she's breastfeeding well the every
every year that goes by
the less i i never wanted kids but it
was always like
you know where we're from that's what
you do you have a kid
by 19. that's just what you do and so i
always just thought i would and then we
got married and i was like
like uh let's wait five yeah i just got
a kid i have a tiny tammy that would be
great
oh my god tiny tammy yes
oh you're just pregnant yeah he has to
say holy
want more vintage cars right right i
don't know
i'm not you don't think about it no and
greg's kind of the same way he's like
whatever you want to do
and every year that goes by the less and
less i'm like so i don't know but
i wouldn't say never but um uh
what was i saying they just don't know
just about having kids and having kids
if you want them or not oh yeah
i don't know well do you think it's
because i don't mean this rude anyway
but do you think it's because like
in towns or like or like places like we
grew up people don't
there's not a lot to do for yourself so
you have a kid to have something to do
almost
yeah in some kind of way yeah for sure i
think that and the pressure that people
put on you yeah okay
every question every question is when
every question you got a kid you got a
girlfriend you got a boyfriend a kid get
a girlfriend got a boyfriend
which i haven't bringing a follower can
i get a job
i hit a million followers yes
because i have that shit i have a louis
vuitton first this is my baby
yeah i have a designer purse now yeah
let's talk about that like yeah
you're breastfeeding the purse yeah i
just had tits you weren't talking about
my tits i just hired a nanny to take
care of the press
it is basically yeah your first louis
vuitton purse it is like having a baby
you're like watching it yeah you're just
like making sure it's okay
rubbing it down yep like making sure
everything's quiet
yeah yes exactly the next million
followers should be thrown out the back
of the car
you have eight of them you'll be like
fuck this purse set it on fire
oh my god no but yeah i just uh i'm
obsessed because i got breast implants
and i'm terrified that i won't be able
to breastfeed
oh and apparently the bigger the boob
doesn't mean the more the milk
you could not be able to breastfeed
which would be an amazing really
ironic tragedy yeah i heard that well
this is
science but the bigger i mean you know
it's okay to not be able to breastfeed
also no the
the bigger the breasts the more likely
you are to have breast cancer because
there's more tissue
so that's why i stopped wearing um i
wear deodorant i wear salt spray
for like eight years now because i'm
like that aluminum deodorant you can't
play around with that
and i was like i'm not i got i got three
times the tip the normal average woman
has
i'm not gonna you know what i mean so
yeah i don't know why i brought this up
no it's because i asked you about it
okay okay
this is a good psa guys bigger tits
bigger cancer if you got
the bigger pitch you have the more
skyrockets the yeah your chances have
you ever done you're not old enough to
get a mammogram
why i have had one you haven't heard huh
does that hurt oh sorry i grab my boobs
when i talk about them i don't know why
they don't feel like they're mine so i
better than like sorry how fresh are
they
hollywood is that the hollywood you're
like these don't like they're mine
because they live in hollywood
i don't even belong to everyone else i
don't even ask consent for myself
to touch myself i don't even ask
permission i sexually ask myself
involuntarily
um uh no these are like three years old
maybe oh okay
yeah well you've had them a minute yeah
i've had them admitted then i had other
ones before but it
when you get breast implants it does cut
through some of the ducks or something
yeah has anyone brought i'm obsessed
with boobs i'm just absolutely impressed
because i didn't have them for so long i
was so jealous of women that did
and the women i know that have big ones
it's such a like a hassle for them
it's like one of those things like i'm
jealous of small titties yeah
and if you're blonde you you want dark
hair if you're you know so it's like
yeah it'll never end yeah you know does
anyone brought the fact that you like a
western gym in the holograms
okay i don't i don't know i know i'm
sure you're right but i don't know what
the reference is but you know
okay i know gem in the hologram do you
know that cc thank you
i don't know all these references well
that was for someone else then well
thank you
someone a lot of people listening to
this are laughing they're having a good
time in their cars
um but more more about army hammer in
your boobs well
my goal for my tits is to every year put
out a calendar
and every year watch them get saggier
and saggier and i'm dead seriously but
if you don't wear a bra they're gonna
get saggier
see i don't know yes of course sure
yes but when they weigh seven pounds a
piece
i don't think a bra is gonna you know
that's true stop
some of the pull i mean i don't know i
wore a bra my whole life up until a
couple years ago and
it didn't do shit for me how do you
sleep i
you know what i can't sleep on my back
uh-huh
because they'll just yeah they go they
disappear they'll suffocate you it is
that is what's so funny about real boobs
no matter how big they are when you lay
down
you have no boobs not flat chest that's
the thing about fake boobs is you lay
down and they they are the
same position they were they're like
alligator eyes there's like boom like
they do not go anywhere
you're like go to sleep i know like she
says we're not invited to this
guys because they're used to when you
lay down them just disappearing
dude can you sleep on your stomach uh i
don't because of
uh my like skin okay okay i can't see
mommy
but also from the surgeries like i had
to sleep
like this like on my back for them to
heal and then i got used to sleeping on
my back
and i i sleep like a mom in a coffin
okay and how did you train yourself to
do that i'm always so confused people
like you have to sleep on your back i'm
asleep
i know i i did it because i was so
insecure about my skin
and face for so long uh because i had
such bad acne
i would get such bad acne and it was
from like oil
and a doctor told me it's like from your
the oil on your pillowcase
and like it's just so i learned this is
i know crazy
i sleep with noise-canceling headphones
on and
straight up so that my face doesn't
touch the pillow while i'm sleeping
and all the product stays on my face
throughout the night i know this sounds
fucking insane i sleep on my back too
but when i wake up i'm definitely not oh
no no interesting no i literally go to
sleep like this and wake up like this
and you stay that way
like a psychopath yeah yeah no i'm a
side sleeper and a stomach sleeper and i
just have to see i literally have to
situate each tit
to get comfortable and then i'm able to
sleep uh-huh yeah you have to
yeah yeah it's a it is a it's like a
full-time job
like oh and if i'm like in a deep sleep
and i don't control what's
where my titty is i will wake up and
it's the
most painful and it gets numb you know
like when your arm falls asleep like my
titty
dude it's like when you wear a ponytail
for too long yeah it's sore
yeah prickly is like feeling so it's a
whole it's a whole thing it's a whole
thing to manage
they're a full-time job where are your
sisters um
in oklahoma no they're here in san diego
with me nice
they uh they um one of them lives with
me the one with kids so
her and my two nieces live with me she's
a manager of
a um plumbing company office
i don't know we don't really talk about
her we don't just now so i don't know i
don't really care you should design a
tammy titty pillow
i know so many women that like you know
that
you have it's like funny and they're
amazing but that are like it's like
it's hard to sleep it's hard to buy
clothes it's like it's a thing
that's true yeah that's true why not i
don't know i i think i will i'm working
on i would love to do like a clothing
line
yes and i'm already start like it's just
in my head this is the first time i've
ever said it out loud
not you know not any time soon because i
don't want to work on other stuff but i
thought man that'd be so cool like down
the road to just
your fashion icon yes thank you and is
your shirt still for sale with all the
boobs on it
oh yeah my eight-year-old niece designed
that i'm obsessed with that i'll send
you i got y'alls merch
and i almost wore it and i thought
that's too cheesy not for me
yeah hillary duff or anybody like hey
yeah
fake
um but no my eight-year-old niece this
this was like two years ago she was
probably six was just drawing tits one
day
and they were all the same and i go once
you change the tits up
and draw different she's she was in a
phase where she was obsessed with boobs
obsessed and i posted it and people were
like please put this on a shirt please
put this on here
and it is our best selling shirt it's
the best i love obsession
hey how about you could be in racist
draw some other boobs the hell is wrong
with you
yeah problematic yeah that's diversity
yeah i could never post this
well and then she started drawing like
really great different boobs and i was
like how does she know
about all the how does she know what is
this breath
spectrum of tips what are you watching
never mind stop whatever you're doing
she just knew she just knew so but i so
many women
and i learned this when um and i talked
about that my last special about when i
went to the
sex robot factory and built a custom sex
robot thing
uh they were they had this wall of
nipples
like all these nipples you could get and
in my head
like every guy wants like a perfect like
like a c cup with a nipple just right in
the
whole thing sixty percent of the
requests the men requested nipples to be
bigger than the boob
like big nipples is a big thing and a
lot of men requested the nipples to go
down
a lot of women's nipples do not go up do
not go out yeah there's also just like
this
this like um like demystifying of like
what boobs are supposed to look like
they're all supposed to look like this
like porn body but yeah boobs don't look
like that
before i got this done my boobs were
different sizes yeah i had one innie
one audi nipple and they like just were
like running out from each other they
were like not even in the same
mine at all yeah you could have done
some in and out
uh some scientists some sponsorships
paid partnerships taking money off the
table
like it's just like it's so yeah that's
shocking to know
really yeah i would think they would
pick you know no
guys are it's not it's like it was like
it like was made me
like this narrative like oh man just
want a size zero
with like it's not these are men
requesting a custom body to fuck
and they're not and they're testing that
and the biggest complaint is that the
all the bodies were too
uh thin they didn't come in bigger sizes
because it was too heavy to carry
because you're like they need to make a
lighter weight um
uh skeleton of the whatever the metal
inside
they are making it fiberglass it was
just too heavy to carry around
it's just like wow did you say custom
body to fuck yes i did wow
yeah that's the most la thing
that's everyone's body in l.a wow i just
mean like
this is like the at the sex robot
factory wow this is like
all of nipples that's a very ted bundy
charles
they got a really see they got it bad
and everybody else has walls of nipples
wall of nipples
the wall of all the nipples you could
choose from and the most popular one
wow was really big nipples on a small
boob
wow okay and then guys picked they
wanted the boob to be
i mean sorry the nipple to sort of be on
the end instead of like
oh yeah okay yeah like one of those
hamster feeders
[Laughter]
how do you clean under your boobs oh i
literally
that's like i've thought that every time
i see one of your videos oh yeah i will
i literally just
pick it up and i'll just wash it
you got to yeah you got i always am like
does she have to like yeah but lo like
is it uh mm-hmm yeah i literally have to
pick them up and and clean them just
like you would
foreskin a ball sack yeah yeah yeah yep
i'm like i feel like she has to pick it
up uh-huh i'm like does she go get in
the bath and just like how does this
work
yeah yep that's exactly how it works
just take a washcloth
and go to the car wash okay 7 57.
one titty at a time um okay are you and
theo doing any more of these shows
yeah well can we see you where can we
find you everything um oh gosh i'll be
back on the good for you podcast
i'll be back i hope please have me back
and please have me back just to hang out
with y'all
i'm obsessed with you i dude i've i've
in my head we've been
really good friends for the past like
year my friend lucy talks about you
probably every day to me
from zany's nashville i love her oh my
god okay
yeah hey just uh search me um i'm
googling you
on everywhere instagram chelsea lynn if
you're not following me
i think that will throw people off yeah
h-e-l-s-i
no c-h-e-l-c-i-e
chelsea lynn art you ever heard of it
mm-hmm
or just we're trying that yeah okay
filling out that name for yeah
um or just search trailer trash tammy oh
i have pages this trick you'll find me
dude
also yeah the calendar hot gift yeah
valentine's day gift yes it's also like
yeah your videos are like they make my
friendship
stronger i love you
thank you i even know how how meaningful
that was as i
said i was first of all what friends
name them yeah name them
who people who won't talk to me anymore
because it was like they watched
chelsea's videos watch it
no but it's like it like it like bonds
people yeah everything now is so
divisive like like
it's look at this meme oh that's not
funny like everyone's such an expert on
coming out like
your videos is like universally like
we're fucking laughing at this thank you
there's no like political like i'm not
you're not yelling at me you're not
lecturing me you're not telling me how
to live
it's just like this is what comedy's
supposed to be
yeah you know what's funny is
those okay i did one all right you know
what they are
it's just people eating which i by the
way when you eat i'm like it's time for
dinner by the way the fact that you just
said that and i'm like i'm like
well they started blowing up on youtube
like three or four years ago
and these videos were getting like
millions of views
we've talked about it i've tried to talk
us into doing it these are just videos
of famous people just
eating no famous food not even famous
people they can't and literally
they'll they'll sit in front of the
camera and some some of them don't even
talk they literally just eat it's just
their mouth and then some of them are
like how was your day what did you guys
do today and it was for like lonely
people to
have dinner with people and then like
americans started doing it as like
youtubers
and i thought this is the dumbest thing
i've ever seen in my life
so i wanted to do one as tammy making
fun of it
yeah and i only planned on doing one and
it
was my biggest viewed youtube people
were like
holy shit do more you know it's all
improv i just make
i just make shit up you know i just make
up a story whatever
and it's not even about the food it's
about tammy just sitting there thinking
thinking she's putting out good content
the way
the way you go into this character it's
like it's
like um you're so in it which makes me
think this is the real character by the
way
because you're so in it like i love
watching trailer trash champion when
she's not speaking like when you're just
thinking
when she's thinking because you're
really thinking tammy thoughts
oh yeah that's funny because i'm yeah
when i'm doing that i am still in
character
like when like uh what do i look for in
a man well
dick for starters like and then she's
like
yesterday fat pussy energy fat pussy
energy it's that fat pussy energy but
like the way you'll just like think
uh-huh like tammy takes her time there's
no rush like i think comics that like
that were brought up the way that i was
brought up are like
there's this like desperation to the
videos now there's a desperation
per minute yeah and i you're just like
taking your fucking time
and like it's such a it's such a
refreshing like tone
that i love the food you choose to eat
you're like you're like fast foods
uh when i get from a gas station it's
like so realistic the character
i'm like i love that because those mug
thing people though do like just like
there's one girl in here that only does
hot cheeto stuff like she'll put hot
shoes on everything yeah
and i'm just like yeah how do you make a
whole career out of that
that's crazy well i over think it like i
mean
it's like i try too hard i'm like we
have to write something we have to make
something we have to shoot it we have to
edit it we have to put it together
meanwhile it's like just eat on camera
and you'll do it
in the controversy about the people that
they're like this milk banger doesn't
swallow the food they cook
who cares yeah yeah yeah it's like they
edit and spit it out
dude yeah so they just they don't really
see you well and that's the crazy thing
is that
the mukbangs are my most requested
videos
they and if i write something and film
something and edit something a skit and
it is so
freaking funny it'll get some love but
people just want to see tammy
eating in a car dude hanging out yeah
which is does it's like is that
it takes the pressure off the audience
to have to judge the content also
when something's really highly produced
i then have to go that was really good
or that was i i mean yeah
that was when it's like we're just doing
the base bare minimum
here so this is just this isn't yeah
you don't have to turn on your critical
thinking hat like we're both checking
out together
yeah you know there's no pressure to
like this or not like this which is why
i like it so much
yeah you know yep yep like i don't
you're not making
me feel stupid you're not like i don't
have to follow a story
i don't have to like i've been watching
that show your honor it's so fucking
good
and i didn't even want to watch it it
just like sucked me in with how
compelling and good it was
and it's like frustrating to watch
because it's like
it's so good and it's heard of it yeah
it's on um it's
bryan cranston's new show uh it's so
good okay
i'll watch it but i don't really watch
dramas for this exact reason
because i don't like it's like going
into a haunted house i'm like i don't
like
yeah it turns out i don't like these
twists and turns and all this tension
i just kind of want to like check out
with someone that's gonna be funny
it's just sitting there chilling for an
hour yeah that's crazy yeah
because watching tv i'm not realizing
after watching podcasts and it's like
kind of like work you have to like
follow the story you have to like
okay yeah that's bad acting like you
have your brain's still working
yes i'm not fully checked out because
i'm judging the show going well you know
what joe was better than this he was
better in this role and he was actually
the breaking bad was better and this is
better than that and it's like whereas
we're watching mukbang it's like we're
just fucking chilling man we're
just chilling dude isn't that crazy yes
it's also a great way to make a grocery
list yup
yep yeah it's a great way to get gout
yeah i've seen some of these smoke
things
oh my god um all right i love you we
have to
we have to let you go at some point okay
i love you how do you feel
she was nervous in the beginning oh i'm
always nervous how do you feel oh this
was after the first
30 seconds great it's gone by so fast
i freaking love y'all thanks for having
me i'll be back
i love you chelsea
[Applause]
you